[Musique]
messieurs bonsoir encore nous vous
recevons pour une chaîne internet qui
s'appelle thinker view nous sommes en
direct est-ce que vous pouvez vous
présenter succinctement nicolas nas
je suis ingénieur modélisation
mathématique et mécanique de formation
physique plutôt modélisation aussi
mécanique des fluides que j'ai fait au
sein du ceva donc le commissariat à
l'énergie atomique sur la fusion
nucléaire ou en tout cas en lien avec la
fusion nucléaire donc qui pourrait
peut-être être développées plus tard
dans l'interview est ensuite fin de mois
d'octobre à je me suis engagé pour le
climat d'abord bénévolement un plein
temps à marseille puis au niveau
national au sein d'alternatiba et
d'actions non-violentes cap21 et là il
ya à peu près deux ans j'ai rejoint
l'équipe salariée de greenpeace où je
suis en charge des questions de
transition énergétique ça va à la fois
de la question des consommations donc la
lutte contre le gaspillage énergétique
au travers de la sobriété de
l'efficacité énergétique
il ya aussi les questions il ya la
production bien évidemment dont la
question épineuse en france de la
production électrique avec la sortie des
énergies fossiles les renouvelables et
le nucléaire
gilles babinet est-ce que vous pouvez
vous présenter succinctement au sort
donc juge gilles babinet je suis avant
tout un entrepreneur dans le domaine du
numérique
j'ai monté les entreprises pendant 25
ans et puis depuis une dizaine d'années
je m'intéresse
sujets de politique publique et du
numérique dans différentes instances qui
selon la commission européenne
le conseil national du numérique en
france que je copréside actuellement et
depuis
quelques années je m'intéresse au sujet
de l'énergie d'abord je me suis
intéressé au sujet des smart grid
je t'ai assez à l'époque j'avais
connaissance assez faible des sujets
d'énergie et en m'intéressant aux smart
grid je suis devenu pro nucléaire et
j'ai rejoint
les voies du nucléaire qui est une
association
pro nucléaire il ya maintenant trois ans
au moment où l'association a été fondée
on va rester sur vous sur toi si je peux
me permettre
pourquoi pro nucléaire
en fait je pense c'est là où on se
rejoint avec nicolas c'est par
préoccupations
environnementales sévères que j'ai
toujours une sensibilité
environnementale très forte et je crois
que le sujet du carbone dans les thèmes
environnementaux est un sujet premier et
quand on regarde comment produire de
l'énergie
décarbonée ou d'électricité décarbonée
très vite on se rend compte que dans
l'équation le nucléaire est assez
central et que ça n'a pas été conçu pour
ça mais ça c'est une des
caractéristiques du nucléaire c'est ce
produit une énergie quasiment
décarbonée nicolas
moi c'est plutôt l inverse en fait j'ai
commencé j'étais pas du tout incident
nucléaire a la base je pas du tout cette
culture militante historique
j'ai vraiment faire un cursus
d'ingénieurs etc j'ai fait ma thèse sur
la fusion nucléaire parce que je
commençais à m'intéresser aux questions
climatiques et en croyant que la fusion
pouvait apporter potentiellement une
réponse à cette urgence climatique et
puis pendant mon doctorat je me suis
conscientiser politisé aussi et j'ai
compris que bas notamment en france la
question du nucléaire elle efface les
questions vraiment importante de de
changement de société changement nouveau
de dit que que c'était un prétexte
utilisé contre ça et puis qu'il y avait
derrière le nucléaire tout un système
politique en france qui étaient
organisés en fait et qui était un frein
à la transition énergétique
alors ce soir je vais vous demander
quelque chose qui à mon avis ne vous a
jamais été demandée premièrement je vais
vous demander à chacun de me dire
comment vous percevez quels sont les
angoisses de l'autre concernant ce sujet
nicolas quelles sont les angoisses de
gilles sur le nucléaire
ou qu'elles sont de qu'elles ne sont pas
ses angoisses et gilles dumas avant la
même question derrière nicolas
alors bon c'est évidemment ses positions
mais j'ai mes parents oui
j'imagine que pour gilles babinet le
nucléaire est indispensable pour réussir
à décarbonés le monde où nos sociétés
que l'on peut pas s'en passer parce que
il ya des contraintes pour aller vers le
100% renouvelable etc j'imagine qu'il ya
aussi d'autres enjeux liés au nucléaire
qui qui font un peu la grandeur de la
france et la grande industrie français
et c'est
peut-être que c'est ça que j'imagine
gilles qu'ils somment les angoisses et
quelles sont les craintes de nicolas non
mais je pense que nicolas l'a dit c'est
à dire que au delà de la nature les
caractéristiques physiques du nucléaire
il ya l'idée de faire un changement de
société et donc son angoisse est
probablement le fait de rester avec une
société qui considère comme extrêmement
inamovible très verticalisé parce que je
pense que c'est un des reproches qu'on
fait aux
lobbys techno nucléaire actuellement et
au delà de ça je pense qu'il est aussi
très inquiets des
caractéristiques des potentiels
accidents donc je pense j'ai pas besoin
de deux résumé différents types de
problèmes qu'on peut avoir avec le
nucléaire est ce que vous êtes d'accord
l'invs et klute sur la perception de
l'un avec l'autre nicolas est ce que tu
veut amender
et gilles est ce que tu voudras amende
et celle ci c'est l'échauffement les
gars ensuite c'est moi qui tu as
non je suis en partie d'accord avec ce
qui a été dit surtout peut-être sur la
première partie et sur le fait que ben
nucléaire est associé aujourd'hui un
système très verticale
c'est ce que je peux rajouter c'est que
pour moi vraiment en termes de si on
prend conscience des ordres de grandeur
à l'échelle planétaire de décarbonation
qui sont nécessaires et des temps en
fait de l'urgence climatique et au delà
de la maîtrise et carbone en 2050
les étapes pour y arriver pour moi le
nucléaire n'est pas une réponse qui est
adaptée en termes à la fois de vitesse
et des chaînes j tu veux tu veut amender
sa perception non mais je pense que bon
après sur les modèles de société la
grandeur de la france sait pas ce qui me
préoccupe le plus saint laurent non
c'est pas enfin oui une france grande
parce que elle porte des valeurs qui me
corresponde mais pas une grande une
france grande pour la fois j'ai pas
gaullien au sens où il faut une france
grande d'une certaine façon par
l'afrique
entre autres je suis pas du tout
françafrique la françafrique c'est pas
dans le vrai sujet pour moi c'est le
climat c'est vraiment le sujet premier
jeu peut développer mais je dois le
faire je pense dans la conversation
alors moi je vais vous parler un peu de
mes craintes si ça vous intéresse pas du
tout
on voit le problème climatique on voit
le problème d'eau décarbonation on voit
le problème de soutenabilité énergétique
de notre façon d'être de consommer sur
des consommation exponentielle on a reçu
récemment des hydrologues des géologues
sur le nucléaire j'entends parler de
microréacteurs de micro machin goût de
micro machin à droite j'entends parler
aussi de problèmes de production
énergétique à l'heure actuelle avec le
parc déjà pré existants j'entends aussi
pénurie de matières premières j'entends
tension dans les contrats de fourniture
d'uranium pour les centrales nucléaires
et je vois que le monde entier veut
passer à la voiture électrique
je vois que le monde entier veut passer
au nucléaire et quand on écoute des
géologues qui ont les mains dans les
mines
ça va être compliqué de fournir tout le
monde alors certes en uranium mais tout
ce qui va avec les crayons combustible
les gaine de zirconium et ainsi de suite
est ce que quelqu'un peut m'éclairer
concernant la disponibilité des matières
premières pour une transition ou un
amortisseur nucléaire
concernant le développement industriel
du nucléaire dans le monde gilou nicolas
est ce que vous connaissez ce sujet là
je pense qu'il a dit qu'on était
d'accord pour que gilles
ils ne sont qu' il ya un paramètre qui
est quand même assez prégnance et les
cours une matière première qui
recherchait ses cours montent et voilà
or les cours de l'uranium même dans le
contexte que l'on connaît où il ya de
l'inflation par tout ce sont des cours
qui sont pas en tension il ya combien de
concluant new gent lui j'ai pas regardé
mais le cours a été une fois c'était
comme si la liste il ya combien de temps
en valeur je ne sais pas parce que je
pense qu'on doit vendre de la tonne et
je ne sais pas qu'elle ait pris la tonne
par contre ce que je sais c'est que les
cours ont baissé à peu près d'un facteur
2 un peu plus sur les sept huit
dernières années je pense que les
auditeurs peuvent assez vérifier
facilement vérifier sur sur internet est
en fait les mines qui sont en
exploitation dont kazakhstan canada
niger se sont aimés qui sont en
exploitation parce que l on des coûts de
revient qui sont relativement bas et on
peut en ouvrir d'autres si c'est
nécessaire il ya beaucoup plus de sites
où il ya du minerai d'uranium qui existe
sur terre que il y en a qui sont en
exploitation par ailleurs il faut
rajouter que quand on passe de
génération ii à génération 3 puis sans
doute un jour de génération iii
génération iv et bien le
dispositif est fait pour que on consomme
beaucoup moins d'uranium dans le parc
connu actuellement cirque si on disait
voilà ont fait perdurer les centrales
telle qu'elle existe aujourd'hui
avec les moyens de production d'uranium
qui existent aujourd'hui ses terres les
mines qui sont ouvertes on a 150 ans on
a 150 ans donc on est bien au-delà de la
transition énergétique
souhaitable voilà alors 50 ans pour
combien de pays et pour combien
dell stable
combien de réacteurs dans le monde 450 à
peu près 450 ouais c'est ça donc voilà
donc imaginons ce qui est très théorique
parce que ça ça ne marche pas comme ça
il ya des réacteurs qui sont fermés y en
a d'autres qu'on va ouvrir qui sont deux
catégories différentes mais voilà on
considère qu'on a à peu près 150 ans de
moi je pense pas enfin nicolas on aura
un avis différent mais je pense pas que
ce soit un problème mais ce qui va
autour aussi l'idée des crimes
combustible et tout un thonier tout tout
ce qu'il faut alors je ce que je sais
c'est que il ya plusieurs façons de
construire ses crayons avec des matières
qui sont différentes et c'est la
première fois où j'entends dire que les
matières qu'ils font les crayons de
combustible pourrait être fait à partir
de produits qui sont en tension
nicolas
effectivement si on reste au nombre de
réacteurs qui a aujourd'hui il n'y a pas
forcément de risques de problèmes de
stocks d'uranium ou même de zirconium à
court terme en tout cas même droit
effectivement pour plusieurs décennies
la question va pouvoir se poser si par
contre le nucléaire et développer à
l'échelle mondiale évidemment par contre
il ya évidemment des enjeux
géopolitiques le premier pays qui plus
gros producteurs aujourd'hui d'uranium
au monde c'est le kazakhstan le cadre du
tri stable voilà on finit très stable
très voilà au régime qu'on apprécie
énormément il ya un an il ya ironique
mais bien sûr il ya un an il y avait des
grosses manifestations au kazakhstan qui
a fait appel aux forces armées de
poutine pour intervenir dans son propre
pays alors là depuis le début de la
guerre ils sont pas forcément très
engagé sur la question mais évidemment
ça peut poser des questions
géopolitiques il ya d'autres pays via
l'ouzbékistan qui est aussi souffrir d
influence russe même si petit à petit il
s'en sépare il ya toutes les questions
liées aux mines au niger et en namibie
qui pose la question voilà de lien entre
françafrique on a parlé ou de dépendance
pays du sud nord pays du sud et puis il
ya des mines aussi dans des pays qu'on
peut juger aujourd'hui plus stable alors
on verra dans les prochaines décennies
comme le cage dont le canada l'australie
même si là-bas aussi ça pose des
questions puisque ces mines sont souvent
sur des territoires de populations
aborigènes ou ou d'indiens d'amérique
non c'est une question géopolitique
effectivement ça peut être une question
de flux et puis à la question ici de la
qualité du minerai ou une centre par
exemple en australie le minerai de moins
bonne qualité dont va vous coûter plus
cher à extraire et c'est donc le cours
de l'uranium pour l'instant il est
plutôt bas moi il me semblait qu'il
avait augmenté ses meilleures années
mais je ne suis pas sûr à 100% par
contre se poser la question de aussi
continuer à augmenter quel impact sera
sur le prix de l'électricité même si ça
reste plutôt mesurée vous et renseigner
tous les doutes concernant les contrats
de fourniture de minerai d'uranium par
exemple le contrat entre la russie et
les etats unis quand est-ce qu'il arrive
quand est-ce que ceux contraints
périclite quand est ce qu'ils arrivent à
sa deadline est-ce que vous avez vous
êtes intéressé à ça en terme
géopolitique je connais le contrat du
niger un qui est un contrat qui a été
très tendue entre
areva la france et le niger lorsqu'il a
été signé parce que il a été signé un
court qui était supérieur au cours real
et la france considérait qu'il y avait
des liens historiques suffisamment fort
avec le niger pour animer est sponsorisé
un peu le cours et faire en fait de
l'aide au développement cette façon là
je ne dis pas que je soutiens ce type de
choses mais en tout cas à l'époque
c'était là la discussion qui avait lieu
à cet égard sur les minerais je pense
que il faut être quand même conscient
que l'intensité énergétique ramener aux
minerais du nucléaire c'est une des
meilleures qui soient cercle ont fait de
l'énergie avec à peu près n'importe quel
autre source hausse le carbone
les sources carbonnais qui sont le gaz
le charbon est évidemment le pétrole eh
bien on a une intensité
de minerais je parle des minerais
métalliques
qui est moins importante avec le
nucléaire si je prends les énergies
renouvelables à commencer par l'éolien
et le solaire j'ai des intensités de
mineur et qui sont j'ai amené le visuel
gelé dans mon sac peut le sortir si vous
voulez qu'ils sont très très nombreuses
fois supérieur par rapport au nucléaire
je dirais une dizaine de fois nicolas je
suis pas vrai oui c'est vrai sur la
question de des contrats il me semble
que états unis veulent rompre le contrat
depuis le début de la guerre avec
rosatom en tout cas ils veulent se
débarrasser par si mes informations sont
bonnes il est déjà caduc depuis 2013
appréciable donc je sais pas si depuis
2013 a été signé mais là les russes
étaient censées fournir x tones aux
états unis puissent arriver caduque 2013
un 0 sur 6 c'est possible j'ai pas les
informations la france elle a pas de
contrats directement d'approvisionnement
avec la russie par contre y'a plein de
pays d'europe qui ont des contrats
d'approvisionnement en combustibles avec
la russie parce qu'il ya des pas mal de
réacteurs qui étaient conçus par les
russes est ce qu'on se rend compte c'est
que pendant qu'il y avait une zone
d'exclusion aérienne un peu partout en
europe on voyait quelques avions voler
et s'était par exemple un avion qui
allait en slovénie en slovaquie j'ai un
doute pour approvisionner du combustible
nucléaire
d'une des centrales en question et du
pouvoir apparemment il ya des raisons
pour laquelle on peut braver un
embargo aérien frappe raisonnée du
combustible business is business is
wrong revenons à nos moutons là on voit
que je prends un exemple et roger dans
le rhône sont un peu ralenti parce que
bon le rhône devient un peu chaud
réchauffement climatique oblige comment
ça va se passer dans un futur où on va
pas pouvoir relarguer
l'eau de refroidissement
des centrales dans les différents
influent couple afflueront qu'on peut
avoir comment ça va se passer si on ne
peut plus prendre de l'eau suffisamment
fraîche pour refroidir les réacteurs
gilles je vois que des victimes
enfin c'est un mythe en réalité c'est un
mythe c'est à dire que le
le df
a défini des paliers qui sont des
paniers environnementaux de
réchauffement des vivres des rivières
donc pas rajouter un degré de plus dans
les rivières et les centrales qui sont
les plus concernés ce sont des centrales
où il n'ya pas de réfrigérateurs de
sueur réfrigérateur c'est à dire ces
grandes tours qui refroidissent l'eau
avant de la rejeter
et edf a mis en place depuis je crois
2009 quelque chose comme ça un plan
grand show
justement pour faire en sorte que ces
problèmes deviennent marginaux
aujourd'hui concrètement les arêtes
central de ce fait c'est maximum 1 % du
temps voilà et donc et ce sont des
centrales qui lorsqu'on les a conçus on
s'est pas posé cette question et encore
une fois on le fait par souci d'éviter
de perturber les écosystèmes dès lors
qu'il ya des dépassements de
températures qui sont de l'ordre de 1
degré voilà donc des heures parfois même
inférieur et ça dépend des saisons c'est
à dire que à partir du je crois 30 mais
on change donc ce qui est avant le 30
mai c'est telle température et puis
après le 30 mai c'est une température
qui subira en réalité à partir du mot ce
plan grand show sera achevé ce type
d'incident va plutôt se réduire plutôt
que sur augmenté y compris dans des
périodes de réchauffement climatique
nicolas j'ai pas tout à fait d'accord
sur surtout en tout cas aujourd'hui déjà
la température d'élévation de roger
entre ce qui est prélevé et ce qui est
relégué dépend des centrales qu'elle est
central où c'est très faible quelques
degrés le central je crois que ça peut
monter jusqu'à une dizaine de degrés
ça a déjà un impact en termes de
biodiversité locale clairement alors
l'un pas si l'on peut le juger faible on
peut le juger pas faible ça c'est une
autre question
avec le réchauffement climatique et la
biodiversité qui va aussi être impactées
ça aura un impact forcément un peu plus
important pour autant c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui ça représente peut-être
un quelques térawattheures donc moins
d'un pour cent de la production annuelle
par contre ponctuellement pendant les
périodes de grosse sécheresse etc ça a
concerné jusqu'à 6 giga du parc
nucléaire si gigas et quels indices eric
c'est ça le sigas et citron choix voilà
ça dépend du type de réacteur mais sans
regret environ six tranches donc ça fait
quasiment 10% du parc installé puisqu'on
à peu près 60 gigas en france donc c'est
pas du tout anodin la question qui se
pose c'est à quel point ça va
s'amplifier à l'avenir alors un terme de
produits de perte annuelle en production
ça va être rester normalement assez
faible peut-être passé la dizaine de
tera watt heure par contre
ponctuellement rte dans son dernier
souffle qui ne soit dans le réseau de
transport d'électricité a sorti une
grosse grosse étude sur les scénarios de
futur énergétique pour la france
concentré sur l'électricité donc avec
une grosse phase de concertation avec
tout plein d'acteurs un travail vraiment
très intéressant de plusieurs milliers
de pages il ya notamment cette question
qui est traité il est jugé que d'ici
2050 selon les scénarios de
réchauffement ça peut aller jusqu'à 15
giga ponctuellement de centrales donc
c'est quasiment un quart du parc
installé qui pourraient être mis à
l'arrêt ponctuellement sur des vagues de
chaleur qui vont durer de plus en plus
longtemps aussi
sachant que on a tendance à penser que
comme c'est l'été il ya moins de besoin
en terme de deux besoins de consommation
il ya la montée des climatisations qui
va un peu faire diminuer cet écart entre
entre été hiver et surtout en fait c'est
sécheresse elles ont surtout lieu à
l'automne au début de l'automne en
septembre ou octobre et jusqu'à novembre
donc ça va quand même être un sujet
alors c'est pas un sujet majeur a priori
d'après les modélisations actuel de
l'évolution du climat
il ya une autre question qui peut se
poser c'est que aujourd'hui les deux
principaux postes de consommation pas
vraiment de consommation d'eau douce en
france c'est l'agriculture puis le
refroidissement des centrales notamment
des centrales nucléaires avec un monde
et un pays qui se réchauffe
l'agriculture va être là sous tension
aussi si on n'est pas capable d'adapter
le type de culture on va avoir
potentiellement besoin de plus d'eau
pour maintenir une production correct et
peut-être qu'un jour au moins
ponctuellement certaines périodes se
posera la question de est-ce qu'on va
choisir de
d'arroser ou de diriger massivement
l'agriculture ou de refroidir des
centrales nucléaires
donc faut poursuivre les recherches et
les études sur l'impact réel et
l'évolution des débits des des fleuves
le refroidissement des glaciers alpins
pinaire pyrénéen c'est aujourd'hui
quelque chose qui est quand même pas
totalement parfaitement modélisés en
fonction des scénarios de réchauffement
qui aura en france donc c'est quand même
une question c'est peut-être pas la
question la plus centrale sur l'avenir
du nucléaire mais ce n'est pas non plus
une question anodine
rte dit eux-mêmes dans leur rapport que
et considère que c'est un signal
secondaire que c'est pas ça le vrai
problème est effectivement ces arrêts de
tranche je le répète qui représente 1%
de la production nucléaire
ça arrivera ce ton oui mais même si ça
représentait 3 % ce qui me semble un
modèle très exagérées ça arrive toujours
dans les moments où la consommation
totale du pays elle est à peu près
maximum les deux tiers de ce qu'elle est
quand elle est en hiver et je parle pas
des pics l'aude c'est à dire les moments
où vraiment on consomme énormément donc
la moitié de la consommation moyenne
donc c'est pas un problème c'est pas un
enjeu par ailleurs il ya un son de
centrales qui sont construits sur la mer
qui sont absolument pas concernés par
ces phénomènes et enfin je le répète son
débit ouais enfin il faudra qu'il en est
son ami en europe sas et voilà on peut
considérer qu il peut y en avoir mais je
crois que les gens qui s'intéressent à
ce sujet ne sont pas inquiets de cette
problématique là mais par ailleurs je le
redis ce plan grand show qui consiste à
refroidir l'eau avant de le rejeter
c'est un plan qui est très efficace très
sérieux et pour reprendre le point qui a
évoqué ni cas oui il ya un réchauffement
de plusieurs degrés du rejet mais le
réchauffement global de la rivière c'est
un réchauffement qui est marginal qui
est de l'ordre du degré en général et
c'est d'ailleurs également évoqués dans
le rapport de rte à ce sujet
1° ça peut paraître rien mais est-ce que
ça bloque on va dire la reproduction de
certains poissons est ce qu'ils se
mettaient au yen à une incidence très
important sur certaines espèces de
chauves souris qui se déplace et qui
sont tués par les pales voilà et pas que
il ya d'autres incidences la question
c'est de savoir finalement dans
l'ensemble des facteurs qui permettent
de produire de l'énergie quels sont ceux
qui ont la moindre incidence est ce ce
facteur là on c'est un des facteurs je
pense que il est très largement
acceptable
c'est aussi une question géopolitique on
n'y pense pas trop mais on a des
rivières qui enfin des fleuves qui vont
dans d'autres pays notamment la meuse
qui va en belgique et à la centrale de
chooz qui à la frontière et qui nous
entraîne avec deux réacteurs de 14 150
mégawatts donc c'est les plus gros du
parc est régulièrement tous les ans en
fait comme il ya un accord entre la
france et la belgique sur le débit
minimal qui doit traverser la frontière
la centrale de chooz et mis les
réacteurs de chaussons mis en valentie
voire à l'arrêt c'est aussi le cas pour
le rhône puisqu'il ya aussi des contrats
entre des accords entre la suisse et la
france sur sur les débits du rhône où là
aussi à les lâcher des barrages alpins
qui ont une incidence sur la production
des centrales nucléaires et c'est pour
ça qu'en fait régulièrement en ce moment
il ya des centrales sur le rhône qui
sont au ralenti le week-end alors c'est
fait ce prix parce qu'il ya moins de
consommation mais pour justement parce
que les barrages surchargés ou parce
qu'ils vont avoir moins - l'arrivée
d'eau etc ça reste aussi une question
géopolitique encore une fois on n'est
pas sûr je suis d'accord sur un degré
dans un principal mais c'est une
question qui est quand même pas à
négliger moi je serais quand même
prudent sur l'évolution de l'hydrologie
dans les décennies qui vient la
californie n'avait pas du tout anticipé
des problèmes d'eau aussi important
qu'ils ont actuellement il ya d'autres
questions qui joue sur l'appropriation
de l'eau douce par par des acteurs
privés dans l'agriculture on voit avec
les méga bassines et c'est qui qui
défraie un peu la chronique
donc c'est au minimum un sujet de
vigilance a bien avoir en tête pour pour
les décideurs et puis pour fortement
ses coûts et le principal problème du
nucléaire
je pense que c'est l'acceptation
c'est c'est le fait que le sujet a été
l'objet de beaucoup de désinformation
qui
met jeu de qui je sais pas mais il ya eu
une forme de de penser collectif qui
s'est créé à l'issue de
fukishima
et qui fait qu' on s'est dit c'est
extrêmement dangereux il faut qu'on
arrête le nucléaire je pense qu'il ya un
renversement de l'opinion qu'ils étaient
ailleurs assez unanime dans l'ensemble
des pays parce que l'on se rende compte
que le sujet du réchauffement est un
sujet premier et donc en france on voit
les études qui se succèdent qui monte ya
quasiment
tous les ans une croissance de l'opinion
favorable
voilà j'ai un chiffre qui n'est pas
encore public mais qui montre que on a
défié par qui comment mais en fait je
peux pas le dire parce que je viens de
voir ça et j'ai voilà mais les coutumes
qui va sortir bientôt on est aux
alentours de 64% des personnes qui sont
pro nucléaire on descend on était au
plus bas on était aux alentours de je
crois à 44 me semble nicolas quelque
chose comme ça donc on a une progression
très forte au cours des quatre dernières
années
parce que évidemment le fait que le
nucléaire soit la façon la moins carboné
de produire de l'énergie
c'est quelque chose qui commence à se
comprendre il que ces coûts le principal
problème inkling alors si on parle de la
france parce que ça dépend des pays et
des régions du monde c'est clairement la
la lenteur et les choix stratégiques qui
ont été faits par l'industrie à une
industrie nucléaire qui aujourd'hui est
en déclin il ya qu on regarde l'état
global du parc de du cycle aval aux
cycles 26 clamons à la production les
règles l'état du parc de réacteurs
actuels aussi claval et aux pères en
construction donc les nouveaux entre
guillemets réacteur nucléaire il ya en
gros des déboires un peu partout
en fait c'est pas du tout l'opinion
publique qui a freiné l'essor du
nucléaire en france ou très peu c'est
vraiment le fiasco de le père qui était
un choix
rétrospectivement désastreux de
construire un acteur beaucoup trop gros
de le faire en collaboration
avec niveau européen puis avec areva que
partir seul de son côté edf qui veut qui
veut lui aussi allé il ya des problèmes
de fabrication enfin vraiment il y avait
des problèmes les déboires un peu
partout aujourd'hui le principal défaut
d'une claire c'est la temporalité c'est
à dire que le gouvernement nous dit que
au mieux on aura des premiers se perd en
pour les premiers et non les
gouvernements et 2037 dans le rapport
qui est sorti et un mois avant le 4 mois
avant le rapport avait été fêté par le
média contexte il disait au mieux si
tout se passe bien 2039 2040 pour les
premiers le père alors il ya eu quelques
arbitrages ministériels imagine vers
bercy qui ont raccourci les délais mais
aujourd'hui on n'est pas du tout prêt et
en fait on a une urgence climatique
c'est à dire que on a depuis 1990 en
france réduit nos émissions de 20% à peu
près
il faut au niveau des engagements
européens donc c'est vraiment un minimum
et réduire de 55 % par rapport à 1990
d'ici à 2030 ça veut dire en gros dans
10ans les / de nos émissions c'est pas
le nucléaire que nous permettent ça
l'argent qu'on investit aujourd'hui dans
nucléaire va on n'investit pas dans la
décarbonation des transports les gallois
nation périodes du chauffage et puis
dans des moyens rapides pour produire
d'électricité comme les renouvelables et
vu la crise énergétique et qui se
profile à l'horizon
il faudrait pourtant se réveiller parce
que on va voir des gros problèmes
sociaux et même peut-être
potentiellement des risques de black out
en france ça c'est très intéressant on
va y revenir pendant l'émission j ce que
tu peux rebondir sur ce qui est dit
nicolas oui alors je suis assez d'accord
avec nicolas tu veux
sur la première partie c'est à dire sur
le fait qu on a une filière qui a eu du
mal voire plus d'ailleurs c'est une
litote à produire des réacteurs et donc
d'ailleurs c'est un peu l'histoire la
france la france est on a une sorte de
juin 40 de l'industrie un cercle à
l'industrie française s'est effondré on
est passé de 20 % de pib d'origine
industrielle à neuf aujourd'hui il ya
aucun pays est bloc occidental qui a
connu une telle désaffection et la
filière nucléaire ne fait pas exception
donc il ya ces problèmes les problèmes
évidemment de flamanville et
le fait est que la filière a été très
déstructuré maintenant si on regarde ce
qui se passe à flamanville et ce qui se
passe à hinkley point où se construisent
deux tranches nucléaires on y passe sur
les ménages en a c'est là on est sur des
agendas
flamanville je pense que le premier
c'est 2007 de mémoire le départ du
chantier on va finir en
inc les 'points on est sur une mise en
production en 2026 pour un lancement en
2018 donc on est sur huit ans
versus un délai très supérieurs dans
l'autre fois il ya une réorganisation de
filières qui a été fait à cet égard une
conception d'un réacteur qui n'est pas
encore le réacteur de nouvelle
génération qui sera la prochaine version
de le p r mais qui est quand même cette
fois ci totalement faits anciens os qui
n'était pas le cas de deux le p r et on
a de bonnes raisons de penser que on
sait désormais industrialisé les opm le
délai total d'un le père il faut quand
même avoir conscience que la moitié ce
sont des études d'impact des études
d'utilité publique circuit un délai de
15 ans il ya huit ans qui sont
uniquement des études et ne vous n'avez
pas le droit de faire le premier coup de
pioche avant d'avoir fait ses études
donc il n'ya pas que l'aspect industriel
dans dance est cet aspect de
construction de pair et puis à quelque
chose qu'il faut aussi ajouter c'est que
on développe d'autres types de réacteurs
notamment des smr est que l'objectif
c'est d'industrialiser fortement la
production de ces réacteurs donc c'est
des réacteurs qui sont beaucoup plus
petits qui font de 200 à 400 mégawatts
mais qu'on serait capable de quasiment
produire en usine on peut en produire de
très très grosses quantités il est
vraisemblable que ces réacteurs
inefficacité assez proche de celle des
des eps
en rapport de
deux
d'utilisation d'uranium et ce modèle là
est très puissant pour décarbonés et
canto comment dire au fait qu'on n'a pas
fait de réacteurs moi je suis un peu en
désaccord avec les glaces et je pense
que clairement les gouvernements ont eu
peur certes il ya eu un moment où tiens
en huile + fukishima et même avant
fukushima d'ailleurs puisque en france
on a commencé à avoir des réserves très
forte sur le nucléaire dans les études
en tout cas les études d'opinion
publique
dans le milieu des années 90 d'ailleurs
poste tient mobile et donc ça quand vous
voulez vous présenter pour une élection
vous hanter compte on avait une opinion
qui n'étaient pas forcément très
favorable vous lancez pas des nouveaux
sites nucléaires et dans la mesure où
vous n'aviez pas d'urgence puisque les
tranches était là pour durer jusqu'à
aujourd'hui en fait et bien il n'y a pas
eu cette décision de le faire donc il ya
eu une erreur politique importante à cet
égard ne leur pas que en france et
maintenant on se rend compte que on doit
relancer cette filière quant à bien des
points quand tu as le sujet de
maintenant c'est trop tard faut pas le
faire en réalité je ne connais pas
d'autres chemins pour décarbonés de
façon aussi efficace et d'ailleurs quand
vous regardez les scénarios de rte donc
rte a fait un certain nombre de
scénarios qui vont de zéro à 50% de
nucléaire vous avez une diagonale
évidente du coup sûr que si vous voulez
le scénario qui dès carbone le plus vite
à moindre coût c'est le scénario où il
ya le plus de nucléaire il est vraiment
dommage que rte n'est pas faire un
scénario
75% parce qu'on aurait vu que
mécaniquement cette diagonale elle se
prolongeait que le scénario le plus
efficace en termes énergétiques
c'est de faire du nucléaire
beaucoup de choses à répondre là-dessus
déjà faut prendre un peu de recul et
regarder la technologie e pers c'est une
technologie qui est naît le projet un
initié c'est en 1989 donc c'était plus
de 30 ans et le nom hop et r est sorti
en 1992 trente ans après
on a six le p r qui sont en service ou
en construction dans le monde ça
représente un peu moins de 10 gigawatts
pour tous ceux qui se pose c'est vous
dire
evolutionnary power reactor le nom a
changé entre temps avec l'idée que
c'était justement une simple évolution
est pas une révolution donc c'était une
évolution des réacteurs à eau
pressurisée
donc ça devait être facile à faire entre
guillemets on voit le résultat on a six
paires seulement qui sont en
construction ou en service une à deux
qui ont démarré en chine 1 qui a été
arrêté en juillet 2021 un problème de
fuite radioactive dans le circuit
primaire qui est pas un problème qui
pose un risque d'accident grave mais qui
empêche de faire continuer continuer à
exploiter le réacteur on a des
informations il ya toujours pas
redémarré donc c'était en fait bientôt
le premier anniversaire de cet arrêt on
a un réacteurs à taishan 2 qui serait a
priori qui ne fonctionneraient pas à
pleine puissance à cause de problèmes
similaires alors là on a des problèmes
de transparence d'information sur l'état
réel de ses réacteurs en tout cas ça
jamais été démentie ni par edf nuit par
l'autorité de sûreté nucléaire
ce retour d'expérience de ce qui pose
problème sur le réacteur opère à taishan
aujourd'hui la pas été complètement fait
on sait qu' il ya eu des fuites au
niveau du combustible donc il va être
renforcée on sait aussi qu'il ya un
problème un peu plus structurelle liée à
la cuve du réacteur du fait que
contrairement aux réacteurs à eau
pressurisée qu'on a dans un
fonctionnement aujourd'hui on n'a pas de
traverser enfin de tuyaux qui traverse
donc c'est et ça change totalement la
dynamique de circulation du fluide ça se
passe pas du tout comme c'était anticipé
les événements les deux événements sont
en partie liées est ce que le
renforcement suffira à faire tourner les
opèrent de façon pérenne pendant 60 ans
sans qui aucune conséquence ou non
aujourd'hui on ne le sait pas
le réacteur in cloud print effectivement
il a été démarré le chantier en 2018 il
devait être mis en service en 2025 puis
2026 là on a appris il ya quelques
semaines que ce sera finalement en 2027
me 2027 même on en est à peine à la
moitié du chantier effectivement il ya
le coc vide mais les crises elles sont
amenées à se répéter dans les années qui
viennent dans les quinze décennie qui
enfin 15 pendant 15 années qui arrivent
et donc des réacteurs en chantier
pendant les temps de crise en aura
d'autres donc si à chaque fois on prend
une année à chaque crise qui survient ça
pose aussi la question de quand c'est
qu'ils ont arrivés c'est le p r il ya
aussi la question effectivement qu'on va
pas faire d eux perd on va faire des ep
r2 donc qui va prendre le retour
d'expérience et c'est de ce qui s'est
passé sur le père un peu partout en
réalité c'est un peu un nouveau réacteur
il ya plus de double enceinte c'est une
sécurité qui refait une sûreté qui a un
peu modifié et c'est donc pas de baisse
de niveau de sûreté selon l'exploitant
mais ça se discute aujourd'hui ce
réacteur il existe essentiellement sur
powerpoint c'est pas un réacteur qu'on
sait quelle pièce on va mettre ou etc il
n'est pas du tout finalisé il n'a pas du
tout été instruits par la scène c'est ça
qui va prendre énormément de temps aussi
alors moi j'entends que il ya des
procédures qui prennent huit ans si on
regarde ce qu'on a fait à flamanville
sur le p r 1 on a commencé à construire
en 2007 alors que le père n'était pas
totalement finalisé qui avait encore des
incertitudes sur telle ou telle pièce
résultat on sait on s'est retrouvé avec
à faire des machine arrière sur certains
composants avoir des composants qui sont
mal façonner et c'est donc il ya eu
toute une série de déboires donc en fait
aujourd'hui industrie nucléaire n'est
pas prête à accélérer et à construire
des réacteurs avant 2035 voire 2037 et
quand j'entends qu'on va faire 75%
nucléaire etc je me dis mais c'est
totalement déconnectés de la réalité je
veux dire moi je crois même pas que edf
soit capable de construire si je perds
d'ici à 2050 je suis presque prêt à
parier qu'il aura passé de perdre 2 en
france en 2050
parce qu'on a vraiment trop de retard et
ribeiro
et j'aime et même tout lévy le directeur
d'edf a dit lui même pelouse où les
visas jean bernard lévy a dit lui même
que aujourd'hui il n'avait pas enfin le
scénario le plus nucléarisé de rte il
prévoit 14 le père de
lévis a dit qu' il n'était pas sûr que
la faisabilité de 14 p r d'ici à 2050 il
ya un plan qui doit être remis mais
voilà donc lui n'est pas non plus
totalement corps fait c'est juste qu'ils
n'ont pas fait donc c'est ce qu'il a dit
d'ailleurs que le définit oui il ya
beaucoup de choses à redire cercle oui
il ya les contraintes qui évoque nicolas
existent mais elles existent elles sont
aussi déplaçables serre que le pr2
typiquement c'est un repère qui est fait
pour gommer
les défauts du précédent tu perds en
réalité il ya 3 e pers il ya le p r de
flamanville il ya un an le père
intermédiaires qui est celui qu'on a
vendu à ta chaîne est content du chinois
oui mais qui est bien meilleur et ce
qu'on fait avec les pointes et puis un
nouveau design et qui n est pas encore
effectivement instruit par l'asn parce
que il est conçu totalement ans et hao
et qu' il faut dire consultant
conception assistée par ordinateur et
que l'idée c'est de faire en sorte que
les processus de validation soit
différent et donc la scène est en train
d'évaluer s'ils peuvent valider sur des
modèles dynamiques des modèles qui sont
sur ordinateur pour faire ce genre de
choses mais c'est plutôt des éléments
qui vont dans le sens de la productivité
et le gros objectif et je pense qu'il
faut quand même savoir ça à l'esprit
c'est d'arriver à voir une production
qui soit plus industrialisés si je vous
demande de faire une mégane et d'en
faire qu'un seul exemplaire et de la
faire au cou du prix de la série mais
bonne chance c'est impossible c'est
juste impossible parce que vous allez
apprendre plein de trucs au fur et à
mesure où vous la fête c'est ce qui
s'est passé à flamanville ça faisait
longtemps qu'on n'avait pas fait le
réacteur et la simple preuve de ça c'est
que en france on a construit 56
réacteurs en moins de 25 ans on a perdu
les savoir faire et on les avait pas
avant on les a construits on a construit
des écoles pour apprendre aux gens à
souder ce qu'il est en train de faire
d'edf aujourd'hui exactement la même
chose on a été expliqué finalement les
attraits de ce métier pour des
ingénieurs pour des techniciens pour
reconstruire une filière ya plus de
filière et donc il n'y a pas de magie ça
va pas arriver demain matin et si on
raisonne a contraint de constantes oui
on n'arrivera pas à construire ne
serait-ce que si le père c'est pas
possible parce que on a une compétence à
reconstruire l'intérêt de cette finale
c'était une filière qui ce programme
sert qu'on peut dire ok si on construit
15 20 e p r est bien le dernier repère
on le fera à telle époque donc on a
besoin de tant de personnes pour faire
tourner c'est à ces appareils on va
commencer à former des gens pour que
ils soient capables de faire on l'a déjà
fait on l'a déjà fait et ça a bien
fonctionné je vais revenir sur ta chaîne
donc effectivement il ya des problèmes
de fuites de crayon est ce que j'ai
compris c'est que ces fuites de crayon
elles ont deux raisons d'abord parce que
explique les crayons c'est une espèce de
gros bâtons qu'on met dans le réacteur
voilà c'est le contenant du combustible
qu'on met dans le réacteur et ces fuites
manifestement ont été utilisés pour
faire les tests
du réacteur et elles sont restés très
longtemps dans l'eau et elles ont été
beaucoup plus sollicités qu'elle ne
l'aurait été si ça avait été une
exploitation normale de zirconium ont
été bouclées voilà exactement elles se
sont mis à fuir et elles ont été
arrêtées pour ça on a un retour
l'enseignement qui est en train de se
faire actuellement une grave que le
crime qui fuit comme ça parce qu'il est
ce que ça fonctionne avec quelqu'un qui
me disaient mais on a oublié tous les
problèmes qu'on a eus quand on a créé la
filière nucléaire où on avait en france
une transparence qui n'était absolument
pas celle qui existe aujourd'hui dans
vous si on a créé par le prendre terme
ou du client français pour avoir la
bombe atomique oui c'est une longue
histoire sur laquelle on pourra revenir
mais c'est le ministre mais c'est fini
oui on
est indéniable que on se servait des
centrales nucléaires pour produire des
produits dérivés entre guillemets qui
permettait de construire les
bombes atomiques mais à un moment on a
commencé à se dire c'est quand même un
bon moyen dans les crises pétrolières de
produire de l'énergie pas cher et c'est
comme ça qu'on a créé une filière ex
nihilo d'abord à partir d'un design
américain et puis après qu'on a modifier
ce qui voilà à créer un certain nombre
de problèmes mais au-delà de ça la
réalité c'est que dans les dix premières
années de cette filière il ya eu
beaucoup d'incidents de type 3 même
des incidents assez sérieux dernier
incident type 3 ça remonte à en france
il ya une quinzaine d'années je crois un
type 3 ça veut dire s'il 3c il ya une
gradation qui va de 1,6 et donc type 3
je sais plus à quoi ça correspond mais
on va dire que c'est le début des
incidents un peu grave avec de la
contamination qui ne sort pas de
la centrale voilà on a des incidences
012 relativement fréquent c'est publié
sur le site de l'asm tout le monde peut
aller voir c'est totalement transparent
l'asm elle même dit que le niveau de
transparence c'est d'ailleurs la
première phrase du rapport dernier
rapport de l'asn qu'on trouve sur leur
site rapporte 2021 si je me trompe il
est le niveau transparence de la filière
nucléaire française est satisfaisant
voilà donc satisfaisant pour je ne sais
plus ils disent très satisfaisant mais
en tout cas il n'y a pas de problème de
ce point de vue là il ya une grande
transparence il ya peu d'industries qui
ont un niveau de transparence aussi
élevé le moindre incident dans une
centrale nucléaire est déclarée donc ça
ce sont des choses qui fonctionnent et
sur teichmann 2 effectivement on a ce
que je te trouve très sûr de toi sur la
déclaration des incidents mais j'ai relu
le rapport de la scène hier soir je
crois ou avant-hier soir
enfin j'ai placé en alerte l'a récemment
qui quand même et de trois petits mots
tricastin alors moi je l'on peut
commenter une affaire de justice en
cours je présente pas une affaire de
justice alarmant exactement donc moi je
n'ai pas envie de la commenter
je crois pas que ce soit nécessaire je
préfère m'appuyer sur ce que dit le
régulateur l'asn en l'occurrence bon je
pense pas que nicolas remettra en cause
l'indépendance
et qui considèrent que voilà le niveau
de transparence est bon nicolas alors
sur sa cas particulier nous on a
quelques éléments du dossier
effectivement il ya des interpellations
qui se pose on salue le fait que la
justice en plaçant part de cette affaire
connaîtra pas bon on va pas commenter
parce que nous même on n'a pas les
réponses les plus effectuées on n'a pas
accès à l'ensemble des informations
l'asn a effectivement
sous-entendu que pour elle n'y avait pas
de problème on va voir si la justice
confirme ou non cette situation pour
autant on est très attaché à la
protection des lanceurs d'alerté y
compris en milieu nucléaire parce que
c'est pour nous un un levier
indispensable pour justement avoir accès
à la transparence de l'information sur
ce qui se passe parce que peut-être que
l'asn trouve industrie nucléaire
suffisamment transparente elle a
peut-être elle a aussi accès à des
informations que nous on a pas
voilà moi ce que je retiens aussi c'est
que effectivement on a réussi à
construire 56 réacteurs en quelques
décennies il ya je vois ce que je sais
où tu vas y arriver
nous narre suis un monsieur très
charmant très intelligent qui a roulé sa
bosse il s'appelle bernard esambert ça
vous parle bernard esambert c'est celui
qui a fait
qui a fait du vin qui a participé à la
création du prêt un terme au nucléaire
français sous pompidou ça vous parle
et donc discuté avec lui on dit ça on a
fait sa crise crise de pétrolière puis
on y aller gaiement et je lui pose une
question très simple je dis mais quand
vous avez fait ça sur un coin de table
vous avez pensé à la déconstruction
recyclage au machin et là il me dit ah
bah non nous il fallait qu'on envoie il
fallait et on n'a pas pensé
après quand on éteint la lumière ou
est-ce que qu'est ce qu'on fait donc moi
quand j'entends gilles je le ressens
vraiment sexy alors on va décarbonés
s'agite c'est facile pour faire ça d'une
façon industrielle va y avoir des petits
réacteurs un peu partout moi je me pose
la question est-ce que ça va être aussi
mal pensé en termes de recyclage de
stockage de réutilisation que le
programme précédent de nos cinquante six
derniers réacteurs
la question que je me pose là on se tape
56 réacteurs l'équivalent d'une bx td td
diesel de 1992
là on arrive à la grosse révision il
faut faire la grosse grosse révision la
finale à 1 on apprend la finir abbas est
un pas l'air d'être le cas ce qu'il ya
quand même 50 % qui fonctionne pas
un
jeu la grande le grand carénage c'est
quand même quelque chose qui est assez
engagé qui s est engagé je sais pas où
est ce qu'on en a dû grand carénage
peut-être que si on est loin d'avoir
fini ça va s'étaler jusqu'à à 2026 il me
semble pour les réacteurs 900 à 4 ans
car il ne cherchait penser au bateau ou
d'être économe c'est exactement ça
c'est effectivement le grand plan d'edf
pour pour prolonger les réacteurs
nucléaires au delà de 40 ans jusqu'à 50
ans pour l'instant
pour l'instant ça concerne que les 32
réacteurs de 900 mégawatts après à
partir de 2028 il me semble ou 2027 il
va falloir s'attaquer aux 20 13 100
mégawatts donc là ça va faire un autre
gros chantier pour edf qui va aussi
nécessité tout une jouvence et tout un
dossier d'instruction parce que c'est
pas les mêmes réacteurs qui est 900 et
c'est pour l'instant l'asn a autorisé de
façon générique la prolongation jusqu'à
50 ans des réacteurs de 900 mégawatts
c'est à dire dans le principe et les
hoquets concours disons tranquille non
tout ça c'était la première étape est
maintenant au cas par cas réacteur par
réacteur elle va dire ben va falloir
faire ça va faire maintenant ça à jour
etc etc ça va prendre effectivement des
années et puis ça va être directeur qui
sont à l'arrêt et qui vont va poser des
problèmes de sécurité
d'approvisionnement ou en tout cas de
tension sur le système électrique pour
les deux trois prochains hivers au
minimum sachant qu'en plus on a les
problèmes plus récents qui sont apparus
liés à la fois au report d'un certain
nombre de maintenant suite à la crise du
coc vide et puis aussi à cause de ses
problèmes de corrosion qui sont apparus
sur des des tuyauteries qui sont reliés
aux frais de sécurité qui sont reliés au
circuit primaire où là on a des fissures
qui sont apparues à l'intérieur
de tuyauterie donc de grosses que tu
loterie alors j'ai plus confiance à fait
de diamètre mais 60 cm un truc c'est une
grosse loterie et aujourd'hui on découpe
ses morceaux pour essayer de comprendre
ce qui se passe est ce que ça pose en
enjeux de sûreté ou pas à quelle
échéance et est-ce qu'il va falloir tout
les remplacer ou est ce que certaines
vont pouvoir être garder tel quel
il se trouve que il est bien possible
que c'est que ces fissures soit présente
depuis assez longtemps ce qui se pose
aussi la question de notre capacité à
les contrôler voilà enfin c'était
c'était effectivement une envoyer des
artefacts sur un certain nombre de
sondes par justice infrarouge
qu'on avait jugé comme muse et
d'artefacts n'est pas un problème et
puis on s'est rendu compte qu'en fait il
y avait des fissures qui était ultra son
nom withera sont dépendants des fissures
qui était un peu importante et un peu
profondes or qui book semblait plus trop
bouger mais quand même ça pose des
questions de si on a besoin de ce
circuit de sécurité de quelles sont les
conséquences notamment parce que ça
touche nos plus gros réacteurs les 450
mégawatts donc c'est pas sa peine
question du vieillissement puisque ses
plus récents qui sont touchés donc ça
pose aussi une question de la fiabilité
du parc nucléaire ce qu'on nous vendait
un parc ultra fiable etc on se rend
compte que que cette année et l'année
prochaine on va plutôt être autour de 3
100 térawattheures de production
annuelle alors qu'il ya dix ans on était
à 450 donc on a perdu un tiers qui est
en partie due au grand carénage mais qui
aussi dieu à toute une série de déboires
et de défaillances sont là c'est un
problème générique mais ça pose la
question à l'avenir de est-ce que c'est
aux autres d'autres prennent génériques
pourraient apparaître alors avant de
donner la parole à gilles jeu j'en
profite pour faire une parenthèse
parce que tu parlais du coc vis de la
crise due qu'aux idées tout ça je tiens
à féliciter
personnellement les personnels qui ont
travaillé dans les réacteurs nucléaires
dont le début de la crise du co lead on
été tenu au courant par nos petites
antennes sur place et ils ont fait un
boulot d'une qualité irréprochable
à se confiner avant tout le monde avec
leurs réacteurs à dormir sur place au
cas où que ça parte vraiment sucette
alors que tout le monde courait comme
des poulets sans tête eux dès le premier
jour il était un prêt et break comme des
soldats à protéger leur vie parenthèse
fermée oui je partage totalement cette
analyse le soleil levant je veux
rajouter c'est qu'on a eu de la chance
c'est que le pic de la crise de
provident a eu lieu en mai c'est l'été
lieu en plein milieu de l'hiver je sais
pas quelles auraient été les
conséquences alors serait pas été que la
faute du nucléaire s'était évidemment
pas forcément prévisible mais ça pose
quand même des questions de de
résilience de deux réacteurs nucléaires
parce que pour la maintenance et a
besoin et pour l'exploitation il ya
besoin de concentrer beaucoup de
personnel au même endroit là où on peut
faire tourner une éolienne ou un panneau
solaire on a besoin juste de quelqu'un
qui vient tous les mois pour vérifier
que tout se passe bien je caricature un
peu mais c'est un peu comme ça
l'intensité humaines de la maintenance
des systèmes vénère et supérieur très
nettement supérieure à celle de
nucléaire dans tous les cas les onze
terme de sous traitance en théorie est
rentré en maintenant s'il ya besoin de
plus de joueurs de densité de personnes
quand un train avant droit non ça c'est
vrai ça c'est certain mais c'est aussi
un désavantage du nucléaire serre que
l'intensité énergétique par rapport à
l'espace c'est à peu près 400 fois celle
des des éoliennes et 150 fois celle des
panneaux solaires
sans parler du fait que évidemment c'est
pilotable ce qui n'est pas le cas des d
énergie par essence intermittente je
vais revenir sur deux trois éléments sur
les fissures d'abord la raison pour
laquelle on a ces fissures c'est sans
doute parce qu'on savait pas les
détecter avant cercle on a des nouveaux
appareils qui sont plus sensibles que
ceux qui parlent de grosses grossi sûr
que c'est des gros spéciaux non mais
c'est la century vous voulez voir dans
la salle fait son travail et voilà ça
c'est le premier rang le deuxième
élément c'est que en france
on a une approche qui est différente de
ce qui existe aux états unis ce états
unis un peu comme dans l'automobile en
france on construit une centrale ont
défini un niveau de sécurité et on ne
fait pas évoluer alors qu'en france la
scène définit un niveau de sécurité le
fait évoluer et toutes les centrales ils
sont soumis donc c'est différent on n'a
pas la même sécurité qu'on avait il ya
vingt ans à cet égard sur le
fonctionnement des centrales et puis ces
tuyaux donc c'est nécessaire encore une
fois de faire ces travaux mais ce sont
des tuyaux qui sont utilisés dans des
quatre secours voilà donc ça montre bien
plus que me coûte fukushima quand il est
diplômé je sais ce que je veux dire
c'est que ça montre bien quand même
qu'il ya un principe de précaution qui
est puissant au sein de la scène et que
finalement on arrête ces tranches mais
on les arrête aussi parce que voilà on
veut être sûr de sûr que y'a pas de
problème et donc ça montre bien le
niveau de sécurité qu'on souhaite avoir
et c'est nous tous rites et de sûreté
nucléaire nicolas avant la prochaine
question est ce que tu vas demandez pas
à demander tu veux compléter non je
trouve que c'est une très bonne chose
que la sûreté passavant prendre le
risque de continuer à exploiter des
réacteurs
alors là je vais vous demander de vous
poser une question la loterie qui
commence
donc le plus jeune a raison nicolas
hauser
n'importe quelle question et gilles et
ensuite gildo posera une question ils
font répondre
de cours
du réfléchir
gilles je veux savoir à quelles
conditions
nicolas pourrait devenir pro nucléaire
j'aimerais qu'on peut te poser de
questions
mais
des choses à réfléchir en même temps
d'imposer la même année
c'est très cher
donc gilles qu'est ce qui permettrait
d'être anti nucléaires
ou pro 1ère en fait non je joue il ya
d'autres choses à un hiver il faut dire
aussi pour ceux qui ne connaissent pas
c'est les ernéens énergies renouvelables
voilà et on parle de haine et rit quand
elles ne sont pas pilotable salaire pour
le soleil et le vent
moi moi je deviendrai promeneurs si on
avait une voie
optimale pour décarbonée voilà et je le
deviendrai rapide pour tout de suite et
la réalité c'est que j'étais plutôt
prouvé nerfs jusqu'à ce qu'un jour on me
demande de faire une conférence sur les
smart grid
il faut expliquer alors ce malgré deux
c'est l'idée de dire on pilote pas
l'offre on pilote la demande donc en se
disant ben voilà on a pas de soleil
forcément moment on veut on n'a pas de
devant où on veut et donc pour le coup
on va adapter la demande et on va faire
des villes qui sont super intelligents
des systèmes industriels qui sont super
un dessin et donc j'étais dans une
conférence à barcelone sur ce sujet
j'avais les leaders mondiaux qui sont à
chier d'air si mince huawei abb qui
était sur mon panel et j'ai été
totalement stupéfait de voir qu'en fait
des plans de pilotage de demandes y en
avait pas en tout cas il y en avait pas
au delà des gros acteurs industriels
pour lesquels ça a toujours été le cas
et j'ai commencé à m'intéresser
finalement à différentes routes de
décarbonation qui pouvaient exister
et c'est là que je me suis dit en fait
et ce qui est un paradoxe parce que les
gens du numérique en réalité et devrait
être prouvée nerfs parce que c'est là où
on a besoin d'information d'intelligence
dans le système pour faire fonctionner
tout ça et pour faire des grid qui sont
dynamiques je savais bien tous côtés des
absorbeurs de data voilà exactement
exactement et j'étais plutôt sur cette
ligne là et je suis devenu il ya six ans
encore une fois par souci
environnemental producer
alors comment je pourrais devenir pro
nucléaire peut-être si on
il était établi que le nucléaire pouvait
jouer un rôle important à décarbonation
à niveau mondial corgan les chiffres
donnés par le giec c'est pas le cas par
exemple à deux chiffres le giec dont son
dernier scénario de rapports qu'il est
sorti le chapitre iii qui est sorti en
février ou en mars il étudie à peu près
je sais plus 50 entre 50 et 100 scénario
qui permettent de rester soit un degré 5
de réchauffement climatique au niveau
mondial et parmi eux on regarde que la
regarde la part du nucléaire et on
constate qu'elles passent de environ 10%
aujourd'hui à en moyenne en médiane donc
autant de scénarios qui voit plus et un
scénario qui voit moins à lui pour cent
en fait la part du nucléaire au niveau
mondial va baisser dans les scénarios
qui permettent de rester un degré 5
selon lui jacques pin sony s'était
retenu par l'ogec qui va rester ce sont
deux gars 5 et pour moi en tout cas les
gros réacteur nucléaire ne peuvent pas
répondre à cette urgence et ses besoins
massifs de décarbonés décarbonation
rapide alors peut-être que les smr à
l'avenir à subir ce mot le mot diola
reactor donc c'est des petits acteurs
mutuel - 2 300 je crois que c'est la
règle même il y en a de tous petits as
jusqu'à 300
pourrait peut-être un jour jouer un rôle
mais aujourd'hui il existe en termes de
prototypes où ils ont fait une unité
démonstrateur qui coûte super cher la
question c'est est ce que c'est possible
de les produire vraiment à la chaîne en
usine et que ça coûte pas cher
aujourd'hui aucune certitude là dessus
et puis surtout au niveau temporalité
encore une fois on est plutôt sur des
échéances dans dix quinze ans le modèle
français on aura un démonstrateur je
prends en 2030 chantiers démarrés en
2030 au mieux si tout se passe bien et
on sait qu'avec edf c'est rarement le
cas donc ça veut dire qu'on créerait
c'est gratuit je suis gratuit mais c'est
la réalité aussi objectives qu'on
regarde ce qui s'est passé ces dernières
bernard année autour d'eux le père et
puis sur différents autres aspects du
nucléaire c'est le cas et puis on va
faire ce démonstrateur ça veut pas dire
qu'on aura lusinchi permettra de la
fabrique et enchaîne ensuite à cette
usine on va mettre quelques années à la
construire puis peut-être elle va
commencer à construire en chêne
directeur les petits réacteurs ce sera
pas avant 2040 au mieux si tout se passe
bien pour moi c'est un peu une un pari
technologique qui qui paraît démesurée
dont tu trouves pas question pour gilles
gilles ça tient là ce qu'ils racontent
les filles industriels et bob brett on
n'est même pas sûr en vain mais
l'entrepreneur il dit on y va quand même
alors je sens un choix assez simple
enfin je pense que
il faut se mettre dans un scénario
dynamique c'est en réalité ce qui se
passe c'est que la filière elle est en
cours de reconstitution et aujourd'hui
je les dis d'ailleurs tout à l'heure
entre flamanville est une clé pant on
n'a pas les mêmes design on n'a pas les
mêmes modes de production et une clé pan
et on est sur des durées qui sont kw à 8
ans 9 ans voilà donc ces on commence à
avoir une durée qui est acceptable en
réalité si on disait c'est théorique
mais on produit
50 comme on l'a fait il ya 40 ans
réacteurs nucléaires ben on se mettrait
en ordre de bataille pour les faire de
façon industrielle on et produira à très
grande vitesse il n'y a pas de fatalité
c'est la même chose dans tous les
systèmes industriels si vous produisez
un iter dans le sud de la france d'hier
ça veut dire il tire je sais pas ce que
ça veut dire
c'est nationale experimental reactor
donc c'est l'astronaute et c'est de la
fusion voilà c'est bon voilà c'est on en
fait qu'un seul ça coûte horriblement
cher s'écoute 23 milliards de d'euros ou
de dollars
et on en fait qu'un seul si on commence
à faire de la série tout de suite on
industrialisés on va commencer à être
capable de le faire et c'est l'idée et
c'est d'ailleurs pas que l'idée en
france c'est également des constructions
aussi lundi commençait alors on en a pas
parlé d'ailleurs tout à l'heure de la
des commissions mais oui quand les
réacteurs ont été construits on n'a pas
vraiment penser à la façon dont on est
les démonter je crois qu'aujourd'hui
dans le monde il ya eu 150 tracteurs qui
ont été démantelés et on a des modèles
qui sont maintenant assez précis du coût
du démantèlement edf avait provisionné
ils ont ils ont paru publiées mais c'est
un chiffre qui va croissant il ya sept
ans il avait provisionné 22 milliards
pour démanteler les réacteurs français
4 milliards par un acteur non non non
non c'est en 2001 10 milliards c'est aux
alentours d'un milliard et on a encore
une fois une expérience assez précise de
sa de tous les réacteurs qui ont été
démantelés dans le monde donc c'est
compliqué c'est coûteux ah mais c'est
loin d'être impossible et c'est loin
d'être une aventure quelque chose qui
s'industrialise et qui se maîtrisent
aujourd'hui nicolas trouve été question
de tout progrès répondre sur le
démantèlement et après je suis sur le
démantèlement effectivement il ya un
réacteur à eau pressurisée peut-être un
peu plus mais aux états unis qui a été
démantelé alors encore une fois les
normes aux etats unis c'est pas les
mêmes que les normes en france en france
on n'a jamais fait sur un réacteur de ce
type on a d'ailleurs des vieux réacteurs
à des mots clés qui sont encore plus
compliqué parce qu'ils n'ont pas du tout
vraiment pas du tout était prévu pour ça
pour être démantelé un jour la question
qui se pose c'est effectivement la
question financière quand on regarde les
estimations qui font fait par les
différents pays européens et ça c'est un
rapport de la cour des comptes de 2012
en fait ce qu'on n'applique les
hypothèses qui sont faits avec un
parlent d'eux mêmes en or gurs on se
rend compte que edf et la fourchette la
plus basse et ça va d'un facteur x 2
jusqu'à foix iv je crois donc 1 3 je
résiste mais peut-être que c'est un à
trois ça veut dire que on a
potentiellement deux tiers de l'argent
nécessaire pour le démantèlement qui est
pas provisionné et qu'est ce qui va se
passer si jamais il ça coûte plus cher
que prévu c'est le contribuable qui va
payer puisque edf c'est une entreprise
nationale qui est déjà surendettés et
qui a déjà énormément de problèmes tout
cas l'actionnaire principal c'est l'état
donc c c'est alors à des contrats avec
areva etc mais une fine et c'est le
contribuable qui va payer si jamais
assez sur coup alors le la chose qu'il
faut quand même rajouter c'est que ces
réacteurs ils sont en série et donc une
fois qu'on a réussi à trouver la façon
dont les démanteler de façon optimale on
peut industrialiser ce démantèlement et
les observateurs dont la scène
d'ailleurs
disent que voilà on est dans les pures
en matière de démantèlement et je
rajoute que le montant que provisionnent
edf qui croît d'année en année donc
arrivera un moment où
bien il sera prolongé supérieur que les
montants qui sont provisionnées tels
qu'ils sont aujourd'hui sur la référence
de ce qui s'est passé principalement aux
états unis
l'occasion de re et ma question chance
si un pays montrer que le 100 %
renouvelable était possible disons en
2030 qui s'approchait vraiment du 100%
renouvelable sur des laps de temps un
peu long de l'échelle de la semaine
son intention google disponible tout
temps avec des flexibilités du stockage
d'électricité par batterie de tests ou
du sel fondu cd dont on arrive c'est
devenu clair
cent quinze jours ah oui ah oui du
stockage bien fonctionner c'est vrai
peut-être plus tard stockage à hydrogène
ou à gaz bas carbone de synthèse
est ce que je serais prêt à devenir mère
ayant peut-être antinucléaires
oui bien enfin je veux dire si le
scénario existe
je serai évidemment favorable à ce
scénario après je pense que la vraie
question c'est à quelle quantité de co2
résiduelles on saura dire que je pense
que un salon deux pays
l'espagne par exemple peuvent passer en
dessous des 200 g la france a expliqué
220 mille pardons en fait on parle de 2
grammes de co2 par nombre de
kilowattheures produits
voilà et on considère que quand on
commence à être en dessous de 100 g ou
de 80 grammes on a un niveau de
décarbonation qui est relativement élevé
la france en moyenne et aux alentours de
50 60 grammes et c'est le parc nucléaire
qui permettent de faire ça
donc s'ils fonctionnent correctement et
qu'on hypocrite non mais en ce moment on
est à ça en ce moment les gens peuvent
aller sur electricity map point org et
ils peuvent regarder tout de suite avec
le mégawattheure aujourd'hui le prix du
mégawatt mais ça dépend pour le
consommateur à consommateur paie pour le
consommateur 180
euros à peu près avec le transport notre
quelque chose comme ça non j'ai beaucoup
moins consommateurs des contrats pour
les particuliers en tout cas c'est des
contrats des coupes bouklit un riche
attend on est à 18 centimes du
kilowattheure
donc ça fait 18 euros ou 104 18 centimes
du kilowattheure voilà maintenant des
communautés de mutxiko les prix de
marché aujourd'hui en moyenne en ce
moment celle de san luis et non mais
bien sûr donc c'est en dessous donc il
ya des pics en ce moment à cause de la
crise énergétique à 703 millions en
france dont 7 450 ou 500 ariary à lui à
gauche mais très très court essai les
marchés elles et christelle c'est ben c
est spéculatif non mais voilà ça a duré
pendant une minute ou deux ils ont
racheté quelques mégawatts heure à un
prix élevé pour revenir à sa question à
ta question
et ben ouais mais c'est ça va être le
problème de la réalité de cette
décarbonation c'est à dire que moi je
vois pas vraiment de scénario si je
prends le scénario espagnol par exemple
qui est un très bon scénario j'espère
que c'est un pays un peu particulier
parce que ils ont deux mers par
définition donc ils ont des conditions
de vent qui peuvent être un peu plus
constante et puis surtout c'est le pays
le plus haut d'europe c'est plus haut
que la suisse par exemple et donc s'ils
ont la capacité de créer des steppes
c'est à dire des barrages
avec deux réservoirs qui permettent de
stocker l'énergie
et donc qu'ils ont un scénario
qui leur permet de descendre assez bas
mais c'est pas un modèle reproductible
donc je suis très heureux pour les
espagnols qui d'ailleurs envisage de ne
plus des commissionné l'heureux leur
nucléaire mais pour autant la question
c'est de savoir à quel niveau en étant
ça quoi en fait si ta question c'était
si on peut le faire pour la france oui
mais je ne pense pas qu'on puisse le
faire pour la france moi je pense que la
france a trois surfaces maritimes avec
la manche l'atlantique la méditerranée
on arrête de l'hydro on a pas mal de
régime devant différents on a plutôt du
soleil beaucoup plus que des pays qui
développent beaucoup photovoltaïque
comme les pays bas par exemple donc le
potentiel en france il est quasiment
incomparable en europe avec peut-être le
royaume uni qu encore plus de potentiel
d'éolien en mer mais moi je pense qu'au
contraire on a un potentiel immense pour
aller vers les 100 % renouvelable le
problème c'est le taux de charge de
l'éolien s'est péniblement du 31 32 %
avec du duo offshore évidemment
aujourd'hui c'est plutôt du 24 %
et donc moi je vois pas du tout comment
on va s'approcher du 50 ou 60 ou 70%
avec des compléments de stockage qui
nous permettrait de faire ça enfin je
veux dire ce scénario je ne vois pas ou
alors je le vois à des coûts qui sont
indéfendables
les scénarios arte qui est juge
justement les différents un coût des
défaillances scénario avec ou sans
nucléaire ils jugent à horizon 2050 la
différence cumulé de 15% entre les
scénarios les moins chères renouvelables
et scénario nucléaire avec du nouveau
nucléaire 15% d'ici 30 ans c'est
vraiment on est dans la marge d'erreur
est en fait c'est essentiellement portée
par le coût du capital c'est à dire que
si le coût du capital du nucléaire et
bah c'est à dire qu'en gros si le risque
que prennent les investisseurs et
garantie garantie notamment par l'état
eh ben effectivement le nucléaire fin
les scénarios avec du nouveau nucléaire
coûte moins cher que les scénarios 100%
renouvelable si on prend les taux le
coût du capital actuel ce qui se fait
aujourd'hui en france entre nucléaire et
renouvelables on se rend compte que les
scénarios sont au même prix donc c'est
vraiment ça la variable d'ajustement et
puis après il ya eu énormément
d'incertitudes liées comme je le dit
heureux de prendre le père enfin il y en
a encore plus lien un modèle
nerfs de mon point de vue parce que ça
repose sur des hypothèses de stockage
qui n'existe pas et aujourd'hui le
stockage
hydrogène c'est quelque chose qui est
extrêmement hypothétique le fait qu'on
arrive à stocker à des coûts acceptables
d'ailleurs c'est dans le scénario
de rte c'est plutôt une hypothèse 2050
pour passer en dessous de 2 euros le
kilo
ce qui rend quand même assez
problématique le fait d'arriver à mettre
en oeuvre un tel scénario alors
qu'arthur il a étudié scénario où on
n'arriverait pas décarbonés enfin à
stocker cet hydrogène il n'a conclu en
gros les émissions de co2 que ça rajoute
est est en fait qu on regarde ce que ça
rajoute c'est l'équivalent d'un ep air
qui seraient pas mis en service parce
que à cause de retard et c'est donc en
fait c'est pas si significatif que ça
les besoins en hydrogène d'un point de
vue annuelles ya des besoins ponctuels
qui sont très importants du coup si on
n'arrive pas à le faire va peut-être
devoir recourir à du gaz fossile mais en
fait pas plus que si on n'arrive pas à
construire les et père et notamment un
seul le père donc en fait c'est une
balance et un paris vers l'avenir qui
est aujourd'hui pas facile à faire c'est
aussi tous les incertitudes des
scénarios de prospective c'est qu'on
sait pas l'avenir et puis sur le coup je
rajouterais une dernière chose c'est que
en fait si on actualiser les scénarios
de rte aujourd'hui avec les prix de
l'énergie actuelle qui sont amenés à
durer pendant au moins quelques années
voire peut-être à plus long terme parce
que est pas sûr que les prix du gaz ou
même du pétrole robert même moyen terme
c'est pas sûr du tout les conclusions
seraient les mêmes et notamment gros
intérêt à développer du foot méfie du
rebond du chat mort quand les prix tu
demandes
après les scénarios de rte il repose sur
le fait qu une croissance des rendements
de l'éolien qui n'ont pas été observées
en corne ou pas avoir des taux de
charges de l'ordre de 45% dans
l'offshore ça pardon pour le parc éolien
en mer ça ouais 45% ça n'existe pas en
mer du nord ici bref c'est plutôt 37
prendre un départ qui fonctionne à 50%
et sur des technologies qui ont lieu
trois ans je pense pas que ce soit ce
qu'on ait observé en mer du nord en tout
cas ce que j'ai signalé
par ailleurs il ya le plus gros parc au
large de l'angleterre sur la côte est
mais j'aurais pas le nom c'est le plus
gros parc britannique a parfois tourné à
52 % mais il a tourné à un moment 50
d'une année mais voilà et le vent a
baissé de 10 % sur les six dernières
années on n'arrive pas à expliquer ça
donc c'est aussi une incertitude
supérieur et puis par ailleurs ces
scénarios pour l'instant le stockage je
vois pas comment on fait c'est à dire
que si j'ai 30 % de disponibilité de
l'éolien et du solaire je dois quand
même stocker 70% du temps et donc ça je
vois pas très bien comment on le fait
avec un système qui est totalement
décarbonée non parce qu'il ya beaucoup
plus de capacités installées et vous
appelez votre raisonnement même pas que
le foisonnement c'est que en fait qu'on
aura plus de 100 gigawatts de soldes
photo ax à ses besoins donc c'est un
trou
puis qu'on la sent qu'on aura plus de
100 gigawatts installés qui est la non
ce qu'a fait emmanuel macron pour 2050
et en fait on pourrait aller beaucoup
plus haut si on regarde le développement
de photovoltaïque dans le monde en fait
on se rend compte que la demande en
france ponctué elle en termes de
puissance c'est plutôt autour de 50 66
gigawatts sauf en hiver où il ya des
pics un peu plus important de données
nos collègues européens
oui mais aussi hors norme dans le
solaire donc en fait pendant la journée
il y aura assez peu de besoins au niveau
européen et du coup on aura un surplus
de solaire qui fait que même si ce
facteur de charge est un peu moins bon
en aura c'est plus pour le stockage les
batteries aujourd'hui elle se développe
quand même 1 8 aces grand v de batteries
stationnaires pour le stockage et crise
aidant le monde en californie a déjà 2
gigawatts et quand on regarde installé
et quand on regarde ce qui se passe on
voit qu'ils arrivent à stocker l'énergie
solaire en journée pour la restituer en
fin de journée que ça commence à avoir
un vrai impact significatif et à faire
diminuer la consommation de gaz alors ça
dure quelques heures mais autour du pic
de consommation entre 19 et 21 heures
c'est des choses qui sont un
développement dans certaines régions du
monde on est plutôt en retard en france
là dessus on a quelques centaines de
mégawatts qui sont qui sont installés
sur les batteries qui servent d'ailleurs
à maintenir la fréquence du système ça
fait constitue la réserve primaire de
fréquences sur le système donc c'est
quand même quelque chose qui est déjà
une utilité aujourd'hui mais avec aussi
la crise qu'on traverse actuellement
développé les batteries ça peut être
rentable à très court terme et ça peut
permettre d'économiser dugas justement
dans des périodes où l'on n'a pas on a
des tensions importantes et où le prix
d'électricité s'envole alors entre autre
scénario repose sur l'existence de
batteries les batteries si on prend la
totalité du lithium qui est disponible
dans l'écorcé terrestre sison
non on a quatre heures de stockage de
l'ensemble de l'électricité mondiale
voilà donc c'est absolument pas un
scénario j'ajoute que ça veut dire
ouvrir des mines partout sur terre avec
un désastre écologique absolue le
nucléaire à côté ça sera une balade
voilà et je le redis j'ai raison le
scénario le scénario de stockage tels
qu' il devrait être mis en oeuvre pour
pouvoir faire 100% vénère il n'existe
pas pour la france certains ont créé des
steppes il n'ya pas d'acceptabilité
sociale pour faire des steppes sont fait
offrir on rase tout on était en france
on peut plus faire de ce peuple dernier
stebe qu'on a essayé de faire c'était en
corrèze ça a créé des problèmes tels que
il n'a pas été mis en exploitation
voilà et c'est pour ça que l'espagne a
une petite chance d'arriver à faire 20
mégawatts de steps qui veulent faire ce
qui leur permettrait d'être aux
alentours des 100 105 g
de production énergétique mais le
scénario français il n'existe pas alors
sur le lithium il faut pas confondre les
besoins pour les batteries stationnaires
et les besoins pour les batteries des
voitures électriques en fait l'on
regarde les besoins en termes de lithium
à l'avenir c'est 90% 95% pour les
voitures électriques en fait le stockage
pour électricité dans le scénario
vertueux il montre assez bien ça dans le
chapitre sur l'analyse environnementale
les besoins sont cinquante fois moindre
un autre scénario où il ya 100%
renouvelable mais comme on sort quelques
jours en fait on n'a pas besoin de
stocker parce qu'il ya du foisonnement
et en fait c'est juste adéquat ce nom
c'est juste des périodes c'est juste des
périodes et le foisonnement entre
l'éolien et le solaire les noms ya juste
des périodes courtes on a besoin
effectivement de batteries etc mais ces
choses qu'on peut faire à ses valises
cet hiver l'hiver qui est passé il ya eu
trois semaines sans vent son soleil en
allemagne partout et en france on avait
le nucléaire donc on a évité sa comment
on fait pour passer trois semaines sans
vent soleil ça arrive les climatologues
nous explique que ce sont des scénarios
qui arrive régulièrement rte traite
cette question donc c'est possible il ya
plusieurs rapports scientifiques qui
montrent aussi que c'est possible les
rapports scientifiques 2 qui fait coucou
par qui fait notamment par des des
chercheurs du cired donc un labo du cnrs
qu'ils ont fait l'an dernier donc c'est
notamment
l'équipe de philippe quirion je crois
qu'ils montrent que en fait on peut
développer les batteries et que ça tient
sur huit années je crois à huit années
passées de 2 jours nuit enfin journalier
ou pas horaires et qui montre que ça
tient pourquoi l'allemagne a passé à 450
grammes alors que ils ont c'est le pays
qui investit 500 milliards dans la
transition énergétique pourquoi est-ce
qu'ils ont tout cet hiver
il n'arrivait pas à décarbonés leur
énergie à ce que 100 % renouvelable
c'est pas possible aujourd'hui c'est
quelque chose qui va prendre du temps
c'est une transition est en fait ces
dons qui fout du stockage il faudra du
stockage mais les besoins et commensal
il faut aujourd'hui ils sont faibles en
fait c'est un ensemble de flexibilité
qui vont permettre d'atteindre 900
scénario avec l'existant nulle part mais
si mais non mais non parce que quand il
ya un anticyclone sur l'europe en hiver
il ya un anticyclone sur toute l'europe
et 6 et de l'europe il ya toujours dans
en méditerranée il ya des études donc
ces trois semaines ça n'existe pas ce
que je raconte ce qui s'est passé cet
hiver c'est ponctuellement sur
l'allemagne peut-être mais c'est pas sûr
ils s'étaient surtout que l'europe
s'est enfin je sais les foules thinking
c'est vraiment ce dialogue singing
français j'espère que ça va marcher
c'est vraiment la réalité c'est que ces
scénarios concrètement il n'existe pas
et qu'à la fin on a besoin d'une baise
l'aude qui soit seul ou death est la
base de la production énergétique et à
l'épi claude qui sont que le matin le
soir quand il fait froid etc mais en
réalité si on veut avoir assuré d'avoir
une énergie qui n'est pas en ce moment
les annonces qui font ils jouent des
centrales à charbon quoi j'ouvre 15
gigawatts de centrales à charbon parce
que ils n'arrivent pas à s'en sortir
avec leurs modèles et qu'il ya une
baisse de vent qui est constaté depuis
plusieurs années sur l'allemagne sur
l'europe d'ailleurs également et que ce
modèle là il est plus qu'incertain il
ouvre du charbon parce qu'à une crise
énergétique les anglais ont aussi
repoussé la fermeture de l'enceinte du
chargeur zouzou plus du club la france
l'a aussi fait les glaces ans à
repousser la fermeture des centrales à
charbon ou en tout cas à augmenter le
taux de cotisation annuelle tous en fait
oui mais c'est les anglais en tant que
mesure elle aussi pourtant du nucléaire
en fait on traverse une crise
énergétique majeur il ya des problèmes
de gaz donc il prévoit au cas où de
savoir peut pas comparer la france et
l'allemagne en matière de nous on est à
45 g 50 grammes de co2 ils sont là en ce
moment il ya un peu de vent c'est rare
c'est rare donc il situe aux alentours
de 200 grammes mais ils ont passé tout
l'hiver à 400 grammes voilà donc je suis
désolé ça ne marche pas et la plupart
les pays qui ont mis les allemands
disons qu'on maintient non mais les
allemands ont mis une très grande
quantité d eau lien quand c'était
dernière qui et combien ils ont misé au
1090 gigawatts quelque chose comme ça
même plus que ça dans le tour de ça il
me semble c'est autour de 90 ans l'idée
c'est de dire j'aurais quand même un
petit peu de vent donc même avec un taux
de charge de
certains moments où j'ai pas beaucoup de
vent mais j'en ai quand même un peu j'ai
tellement tellement d'éolien que
j'arrive à produire pour faire
fonctionner mon système électrique en
réalité ça marche pas est ce qu'on monte
dans les parcs au danemark et qui sont
départ qui sont pourtant en offshore
c'est-à-dire dans des zones ventées
c'est que vous passez de sang pour son
introduction ça arrive à 0 en l'espace
d'une journée et il ya des graphiques
qui sont extrêmement claires là-dessus
qui montre ça c'est à dire que sur une
année vous ne cessez de faire ce genre
de choses et le foisonnement européen ça
n'existe pas ça s'explique les
climatologues c'est à dire que de
gibraltar
au cap nord vous pouvez avoir un
phénomène climatique qui est vous pouvez
avoir du vent où vous pouvez ne pas
avoir de vent et vous pouvez avoir des
nuages en même temps et ces phénomènes
là ils sont fréquents non le fil aucune
foisonnement c'est pas binaire c'est pas
ça marche ça marche pas c'est des degrés
plus ou moins élevé il ya un
foisonnement qui existe toujours qui est
plus ou moins important alors ça veut
pas dire qu'avec d'éolien on va faire
100 % de l'électricité en permanence sa
non clairement mais il ya effectivement
une une compensation entre les
différentes régions du monde et par
exemple quand un autre cyclone sur le
nord de l'europe très souvent il ya
beaucoup de vent en méditerranée parce
que c'est justement le bas de
l'anticyclone donc ça veut dire qu'on
pourrait mettre des éoliennes flottant
et transporter une partie ce pas suffire
pour approvisionner entièrement l'europe
mais combiné à l'hydraulique qui en
scandinavie avec le solaire etc ça va
permettre d'aller progression semble en
fait ce que tu dis ça veut dire
construire l'infrastructure de bureau à
des coudes et l'iran pour avoir des taux
de charge qui sont extrêmement faibles
et transporter l'énergie d'un bout à
l'autre de l'europe qui est extrêmement
coûteux parce qu on est obligé de faire
des lui des lignes comme les allemands
ont fait à 800 800 kilovolts qui
traverse le pays qui ont coûté une
fortune qui sont d'ailleurs visibles de
moi j'étais en allemagne a pas très
longtemps on voit ces trucs c'est c'est
des poteaux électriques qu'on n'a pas
l'habitude de voir en france et deux sur
quoi le dispositif ne fonctionne pas
ça calme on n'est pas d'accord mais
visiblement on n'est pas d'accord mais
les faits sont quand même là c'est à
dire que si les gens vont sur
electricity ma point org ils peuvent y
aller quand ils veulent ils peuvent
passer du temps dessus ils peuvent voir
les interconnexions qui sont clairement
détaillées et ils vont constater comme
moi je le fais aujourd'hui que son
stockage ça ne fonctionne pas une
transition énergétique ses 50 ans c'est
quelque chose c'est un long chemin à
dire que ça fonctionne pas parce qu' à
l'instant t l'allemagne n'a pas
suffisamment baisser ses émissions mais
elles ont baissé leurs 50 ans c'est
c'est de dire en fait les voitures
électriques ça fonctionne pas parce
qu'aujourd'hui ça représente 1% de du
marché en fait ça n'a pas de sens c'est
quelque chose qui est progressive le
besoin de stockage on sait qu'il n'aura
vraiment besoin pour continuer à ronger
les énergies fossiles à partir de 2030
2035 aujourd'hui quand il ya des
renouvelables qui sont installés en
allemagne elle ronge le fossile qui est
déjà présent depuis des décennies donc
en fait c'est pour ça qu'il développa le
stockage parce que on n'a pas vraiment
de surplus importants en europe de
renouvelables pour l'instant mais quand
il y en aura il y aura un modèle
économique qui se développera il y aura
une et christique lutra vraiment pas
cher et qui permettra de stocker
l'électricité pour les moments on a
besoin mais quelle stockage les
batteries qui sont déjà en développement
dans paint régions du monde et
l'hydrogène possible l'hydrogène verts
qui en train de se développer et qui
devient compétitrices adverse et 2050
pour repasser en dessous de 2 euros le
langage à lyon alors ça a beaucoup
changé avec la crise heures et moi je
n'ai rencontré les gens de tyson sur les
leaders dans ce domaine et qui m'ont dit
on va mettre encore 30 ans avant
d'arriver à avoir des coûts compass
titre est bien mais en fait l'hydrogène
grille aujourd'hui ne coûte plus de 2
euros ou 1 euro 50 mégawatts l'hydrogène
webinaire oui je finis aujourd'hui avec
la crise énergétique l'hydrogène gris
qui coûtait 25 2 euros par kilo coûte
aujourd'hui quelque chose comme je crois
7 euros par kilo et en fait c'est devenu
compétitif avec l'hydrogène verts qui
coûte à peu près entre 5 et 10 kg 10
euros par kilo donc en fait aujourd'hui
avec la crise actuelle hydrogène vert
devient compétitif ce qui est tant mieux
parce que ça va nous permettre de teck
décarbonés en partie notre industrie et
puis de développer des moyens en tout
cas les recherches nécessaires pour le
stocker j pour cause est passée comme je
suis pas d'accord parce que la réalité
c'est pour que ce soit économique pour
que ça fonctionne il faut arriver dans
dessous de 2 euros par kilo voilà il
parle de 7 euros par kilo voilà c'est
relatif c'est qu'en comparaison avec
l'hydrogène gris si c'est moins cher que
l'hydrogène gris bas les adversaires
vont acheter de l'hydrogène l'air c'est
quoi une cliente parce qu'il ya le coût
carbone dedans effectivement mais malgré
tout je suis désolé pour qu'on arrive à
quelque chose qui soit compétitive par
rapport à l'énergie nucléaire c'est
d'arriver en dessous de 2 euros par kilo
sous l'hypothèse d'une ingénue claire
qui fonctionne qu'on arrive à construire
des épées r oui ok mais sauf que on
commence à y arriver un peu là pour le
moment le contrat qu'on a signés avec
les britanniques c'est un contrat
rentable qui va rapporter beaucoup
d'argent edf ça je ne crois pas enfin
les pas parce que le contrat est signé à
edf a encore publié un document sur les
marges qui prévoyait faire sont des
marges qui sont extrêmement positives le
directeur financier les nefs avait
démissionné parce qu'il a démissionné
pour des raisons industrielles parce
qu'ils pensaient qu'il y avait un risque
industriel trop important sur le bilan
est là on le voit on a un retard qui a à
peu près le même durée que celle du
confinement sur le projet inc les
pointes et la deuxième tranche du clap
hanz va 40 % plus vite que la première à
produire ce qui est fait mon point sur
l'effet de série la réalité c'est qu'on
a pris huit mois de retard en un an et
demi donc en fait à peine à la moitié du
chantier on ne sait pas du tout quand
quand le père de l'épaule va être mis en
service donc ça sera au mieux en 2027
edf sa façon a aucune garantie sur wii
mais edf publié il ya trois ans début je
crois que début janvier 2019 edf disait
le père de flamanville sera mis en
service à la fin de l'année on est trois
quatre ans après c'était le moment de
l'absorption d'areva et ça posait
d'énormes problèmes industriels on n'est
plus du tout dans la même dynamique et
edf a expliqué qu'effectivement on est
aux alentours on doit passer les 50 % du
chantier actuellement mais que les
grands enjeux techniques les enjeux les
plus complexes sont aujourd'hui
maîtrisée
bon je pense qu'on n'arrivera pas à vous
mettre d'accord sur ce petit détail
moi j'ai une question à vous poser
concernant leur traitement des déchets
le stockage des déchets
alors on a vu qu'en allemagne il faisait
des grands troupes il balancé sousse el
harrach dans les années 70-80 c'est ce
moment là faire tout le monde l'appelle
alors on a fait des gros trous qui
aurait balancé ça en mer pierre vas-y
que c est pas grave ça va se diluer et
puis en fait non
libye tout en mer se retrouve au fond
pour la france à a pas fait ça ou alors
pas depuis bas depuis juin quand encore
ici ça ça dure longtemps j'ai
l'impression la demi vie de du plutôt dû
à ça dépend des matches évidemment
mais on reviendra sur les crayons aux
boks le mox un box
c'est quoi le mox ont ouvert à ça plus
tard mais revenons sur les déchets on en
fait quoi on les stocke verticales
horizontales on les stocke pas on évite
d'en faire ça va représenter un danger
c'est pas un danger a dit gilles voilà
la france a proposé est en toi
décroissent tenait bien se passer la
france a proposé de mettre en place un
plan cigéo en fait c'est un stockage en
grande profondeur aux alentours de 450
500 mètres dans une couche argileuse
stable depuis des millions d'années donc
elle bouge je me souviens plus je crois
que c'est quelque chose de 5 mm tous les
mille ans
il n'y a pas d'eau donc ya pas de risque
de contamination
des nappes phréatiques
est à peu près tous les risques
possibles et imaginables qui puisse être
des incendies
même des explosions sont considérées
comme nulles à cet égard je rajouterais
que en france jusqu'à présent personne
n'est mort de la gestion des déchets
nucléaires serre que c'est l'industrie
la plus transparence qui puisse exister
cercle le moindre déchet à une plaque
d'immatriculation de picot
depuis que on a bien près les gros trous
des guinness par voilà c'est ça depuis
qu'on a une filière nucléaire intégré c1
depuis hier mon avis une quarantaine
d'années au moins quoi j'ai pas été
regardé ce qui se passait avant quand
c'était le complexe militaro nucléaire
qui est effectivement le mélange des
jours n'était pas souhaitable entre
guillemets mais donc l'idée c'est de
faire du stockage de grandes profondeurs
ce à quoi gripping greenpeace s'oppose
de façon extrêmement faire parce qu'il
voit bien que le problème disparaît dès
lors que l'on met ses
déchets dans cette zone de stockage ils
sont stables ils sont maîtrisés et il ya
plus de problème alors qu'eux aussi sont
stouky donc quoi
alors c'est compliqué parce que d'abord
on parle des déchets de haute activité
sert ce qu'ils sont effectivement ce que
tu viens d'évoquer sa longue vie ou qui
ont un rayonnement qui est qui est élevé
et donc qui notamment diffuse une
certaine chaleur donc on les met dans
une piscine et puis après on va les
stocker
en bas on les met dans des billes de
verre qui sont elles mêmes dans des
conteneurs en acier béton et puis on les
entrepose dans
ce stockage où ils sont descendus par
une rampe et on prévoit d'avoir un
dispositif de stockage qui permettrait
de stocker tout ce qu on produirait
jusqu'en 2100 si on le lance est
aujourd'hui la cie béton sur 1000 ou
non ça tient pas un million mais même
enfin hockey imaginons que c'est le seul
truc qu'on ne sait ce qui se passe les
seuls trucs qu'on a retrouvé noémie
lancer des pyramides d'égypte mais très
bien
imaginer
ça a été conçu pour tenir extrêmement
longtemps et puis il faut bien
comprendre que ces matières aussi
fissible qu'elle soit malgré tout elle
se refroidissent assez vite l'exemple de
tchernobyl est là pour le démontrer
c'est à dire que les les zones chaudes
au bout de vingt ans il y en a plus les
soldats russes qui sont mus et océans et
les gains positifs c'est totalement faux
faire les gens écrivent ces trous voilà
on a été mesurée au fond des trous qui
la veille avait pas de radioactives
c'était du pipeau de qui je ne sais pas
d'accord donc ya pas eu de russes malade
c'était de la propagande 5 j'ai lu un
article que les gens peuvent trouver
dans le new york times assez détaillé
assez long et qui racontait que c'était
faux il ya eu des mesures qui ont été
faites en a pas et je ne crois pas qu'un
journaliste du new york times soit
capable d'aller interviewer ces jours là
qui sont rentrés en russie par contre
c'est assez facile d'aller regarder ce
qui au fond des trous
si facile à les regarder au fond d'un
trou de 500 m
mais des caméras on met pas de caméra la
position de greenpeace sur le stockage
du nucléaire quand j'écoute gilles alors
c'est tout bout c'est dans des billes de
verre
pays tout mois ci c'est fait pour durer
mille ans et tout va bien se passer
un cynique ou lapins de questions alors
enfin plusieurs éléments la première
c'est déjà rappelé que ces déchets ils
ont été fabriqués sans avoir de
solutions de gestion pour l'avenir donc
ça veut dire qu'on a créé des choses
sans savoir ce qu'on allait en faire ça
c'est un fait et aujourd'hui on se
retrouve avec des déchets haute à 8,6
autre temps autre activité vie longue et
moyenne activité à vie longue pour
lesquels il faut trouver une solution
et pour lesquels il faut trouver la
moins mauvaise des solutions entre
guillemets puisqu'ils sont là et on va
pas les empêcher
la première chose c'est éviter d'en
produire encore plus d'où la sortie
progressive du nucléaire que l'on porte
à horizon de trois décennies
ça ses premiers éléments ensuite sur le
projet de 2,6 et au on est très loin de
quelque chose qui va être réglé en
quelques mois en fait il faut bien avoir
conscience des échelles de temps aussi
de studio 6 géo c'est quelque chose qui
est toujours en phase en tout cas
d'autorisation etc il ya eu un avis de
la haute autorité environnementale qui
pose un certain nombre de questions etc
etc ensuite avoir le chantier qui va
être mis en place une phase
expérimentale
réversible et ses appuis une phase où
est entreposé et c'est in fine et la
fermeture de six you qui est prévue
aujourd'hui c'est pas avant 2150
donc c'est dans plus de 130 ans donc
pendant 130 ans on va devoir déjà
continuer à gérer ce site et continuer à
alimenter en déchets radioactifs etc et
c'est pareil on parler un peu du mox
mais on y reviendra peut-être après le
mac ce qui sort des centrales à voir le
moc si vous expliquer ce que c'est donc
le mox est une des
du résultat du retraitement des déchets
qui est vendu par par orane eau et en
fait c'est un
combustible alternatif qui est fait à
partir de plutonium à peu près 8 % je
crois de plutonium et d'uranium appauvri
ce mox est fabriqué à malvesi près de
narbonne - l'usiné melox usine
d'ailleurs qui va très très mal qui
fonctionne très très mal il ya
actuellement un box sur deux qui enfin
un un jeu de boxe sur deux qui sort qui
est foutue en fait qui n'est pas aux
normes convenable et que du coup qui va
finir en déchets
alors les je crois qu'ils seront
arrêtées donné des chiffres officiels
bizarrement depuis quelques années
historiquement c'était plutôt je crois
30%
entre 15 et 30% de robin appelle çà et
là les chiffres actuels c'est 50% et
l'usiné va mal elle est régulièrement
qui a je pense que c'est même les
chiffres donnés par aura nommé à
vérifier ou alors c'est enfin il me
semble mais
à vie riche et en tout cas l'usiné elle
va très très mal elle fonctionne très
mal il ya beaucoup de problèmes sur sur
la qualité en reste que ce soit très
homogène les pastilles de mox qui sort
et c'est pas du tout le cas il ya un
gros problème une homogénéité qui font
que du coup ils peuvent pas être prises
en réacteur
est en fait ce qu'il faut savoir c'est
qu'une fois que ce mox est utilisé un
réacteur
après il est très difficilement
retraitables et recycle recyclage une
seconde fois en france en tout cas
courte échéance même moyen et long terme
avant au moins la fin du siècle voire
plus tard on ne sait pas prévu ce mox il
est extrêmement radioactif et il doit
être refroidi pendant des décennies je
crois que ses 50 ans en piscine
refroidir 50 en officine ce qui pose
aussi la question de la saturation des
piscines qui en vrai sujet actuel mais
si on veut le stocker je crois que ça va
quasiment presque 100 ans de
refroidissement des piscines donc en
fait on arrive à des échelles de temps
qui qui potentiellement si on construit
de nouveaux et ppr qui vont aller
jusqu'à deux mille
2000 sans quasiment en fonctionnement
s'il fonctionne 60 ans
ainsi si les boks
le père a été vendu au début comme
pouvant fonctionner avec 100% de boxe
alors je crois qu'ils sont vite revenus
de suez il prévoit plutôt 30% maximum de
mox mais si on utilise du mox pour les
eps en fait on pourra pas le stocker
avant 2002 sans presque ça veut dire que
si jo n'est plus adapté donc qu'est-ce
qui est prévu aujourd'hui sont
construits nouveau au père est ce qu'on
refait un deuxième 6 géo est ce qu'on
fait pas de mox dans le père tout ça
c'est des questions qui sont aujourd'hui
pas établie et en fait du coup ce
ce prototype c'est pareil si léo c'est
encore une phase expérimentale c'est
quelque chose qui est pas du tout abouti
il ya encore beaucoup de questions qui
se posent aussi sur les déchets
vitrifiés qui sont pas du tout le verre
des défis vitrifiés qui n'est pas du
tout aussi lisse que orane au levant
dans sa communication et qui apparemment
est plutôt un morceau il paraît que
quand on visite une usine de la hague on
entend le faire crépiter sont au pied de
ces déchets vitrifiés
poser la question de l'infiltration
d'eau dans ces déchets vitrifiés je
crois qu'il ya des études publiées dans
les journaux scientifiques car j'ai pas
le nom en tête aux états unis sur la
question de de la dégradation des
déchets vitrifiés par infiltration d'eau
donc ça c'est une vraie question il ya
une autre question aussi sur les déchets
beats me bitty mines eux qui sont des
vieux déchets nucléaires on a mis du
bitume en fait pour pour en gros stocker
la radioactivité qui eux présentent des
risques d'incendié il ya une question
aussi des fuites d'hydrogène qui
pourrait amener à un incendie ou une
explosion tout ça c'est des questions
qui sont aujourd'hui pas totalement
réglé encore et pour lequel ben voila se
pose en fait plus généralement se poser
la question de quand faut-il prendre une
décision pour gérer ces matières
nucléaires quand on estime que d'un
point de vue scientifique on est assez
mature on est assez sûr de nous pour
mettre en place une solution de stockage
à long terme de ces déchets là est ce qu
entre temps entre temps en avançant vers
cette même rue curie t il faut les
stocker asec ensuite sur face près des
centrales comme nous le recommande ou
pas c'est des vrais questions qui se
posent les comme on le voit sur les
déchets qui ont été envoyés en mer les
solutions qui était pro né il ya 50 ans
pour gérer les déchets aujourd'hui elles
sont inacceptables qui peut dire que
dans cinquante ans cigéo sera acceptable
en termes en termes d'émissions en
termes de risque de sûreté etc personne
donc ça pose pas mal de questions parce
qu'on est sur des échéances le plus d'un
siècle c'est à dire qu'on doit trouver
des solutions pour une durée plus
lointaine que ce qui s'est passé depuis
la production des premiers réacteurs
nucléaires
gilles hypothéquant ce qu'il ya où il
ya beaucoup de choses qui sont des
confusions
d'une chose à l'autre c'est à dire
qu'effectivement les piscines
aujourd'hui elles sont pleines elles
sont pleines parce que on n'a pas si
gérard archi pleines elles sont pleines
effectivement enfin et ce soir si
plaindre mais on ne continue
l'exploitation et on y arrive à le faire
dans des conditions qui sont jugées
satisfaisantes par l'asn quand même hein
pour l'instant oui mais c'est le propre
de toute activité industrielle
le coup le coup de sa baisse et se
construit des piscines potentiellement
parce que mon pisi qui sont pas sécurisé
hic avec un lra s'élançant quelques
nantis charges soient faits incriminés
sont sécurisés com ou
sur des sites nucléaires west ham est
d'accord eux ils sont bien entendu
attentes autant là j'en profite
à côté de toi yagan pis greenpeace tu
sais c'est les petits gars qui se pointe
le matin pour aller faire chier jonas la
première enceinte qui se font arrêter
effectivement alors qu'ils sont pas
méchants parce que c'est greenpeace
est-ce qu'ils sont rentrés dans une
piscine nucléaire non mais moi je peux
leur expliquer a pas de problème est ce
que tu as déjà vu la tête du toit d'une
piscine enfin ça ressemble à quoi un
toit d'une piscine nucléaire est ce que
je peux répondre mais je te pose une
question sa ressemblance j'ai pas vu le
toit les psys nucléaire d'accord
aucune piste ça ressemble à quoi le pose
une piscine nucléaire et en gare
[Musique]
moi je me pointe avec un cessna a craqué
la gueule les mirage les rafales qu'on a
me vois pas où je prends un petit drone
je me pose dessus je pense qu'être kg de
ces cas on est tranquille c'est ça c'est
une question qui se pose c'est une
question qui se pose dans
ce que je peux à dire aussi c'est que ça
fait un certain nombre d'années que
différentes autorités ont donné leur
avis sur 6 géo et qu' il faut que
quelqu'un ait le courage de politique
d'appuyer sur le bouton et on le fait
pas pour l'instant et donc ces déchets
continuent à être entreposées à
l'extérieur dans des piscines ou à
l'extérieur et qu'il faut pas s'étonner
après si on peut crier au loup en disant
à gipoulou normal on a des déchets qui
sont partout c'est super dangereux et
c'est la meilleure façon d'arriver à
avoir un traitement continu des déchets
c'est de créer un espace qui
effectivement va durer sur un siècle de
la gestion des déchets et je veux dire
j'entends bien ce que peut dire nicolas
mais même si d'aventuré il y avait des
fuites d'éléments radioactifs on est à
500 mètres sous terre dans une enceinte
en béton qui fait deux mètres
d'épaisseur qu'est-ce qu'on peut avoir
comme risque à cet égard moi je te
prends l'exemple suivant un ado n'y a
pas d'eau par ailleurs je te prends
l'exemple charmant à ce qu'il disait
l'endroit de stockage aux états unis si
mes souvenirs sont bons il voulait il
voulait pour les cinq cent prochaines
années pour les générations futures si
on oubliait le site il voulait mettre
une image suffisamment parlante pour
éviter que les liens il a la même chose
sur ces rencontres et la designer hisser
le christ et ça quand ils s'appellent ce
peintre la caf et le cri de la
communauté vingaard de winch non 200 ch
c'est ça quand même
et donc donc on obligé de mettre une
peinture alors déjà qu'on est pas
capable mais qui va faire un trou pour
aller à 500 mètres de profondeur
traverser une enceinte en béton pour
ouvrir après des conteneurs qui sont eux
mêmes en béton enfin je vois pas très
bien le truc quoi faut vraiment être
maso mais qui va fêter en tendant à ce
que dit gilles ça n'existe pas enfin je
veux dire ça n'existe pas et est
peut-être un fort un jeu plus tard donc
oui un type qui va vouloir chercher du
pétrole et qui va tomber là dessus c'est
enfin je suis bien il faut arrêter quoi
autant je pense que mettre ça dans la
mer c'est juste complètement délirant et
on l'a fait là dessus déjà en prison
maintenant tout ça je sais pas j'espère
mais ça devrait être le cas quoi c mais
c'est une autre époque c'est une époque
où on savait pas ce que c'était on
faisait n'importe quoi voilà là on parle
d'une gestion industrielle de déchets
pour faire fonctionner une filière qui
est le meilleur outil décarbonation qui
soit et je pense que ce point est un
point qui est du même niveau que le
réchauffement des rivières c'est pas des
colons ce qu'il raconte non plus qu'est
ce qui nous dit que dans 50 ans on ne
dira pas de nous ce qu'on disait sur le
largage gerber est bon mais mais moi
c'est un peu ça il faut agir il ya eu à
dire quoi après il faut agir il ya le
réchauffement qui me chiffonne
climatique est à quai on a une crise
énergétique on à la corde russe autour
de la gorge ou la laisse ça dépend de
quel côté rose oui il faut une
indépendance énergétique
on est censé réindustrialiser la france
on est obligé où on est obligé de je
vais très vulgaire on obligé de se
sortir les doigts là ça fait 40 ans que
nos politiques vivote sur la fin des
trente glorieuses
bénéficie du vernis des plans
industriels que nous aillons pu faire
avec leurs impôts
là ça devient compliqué donc on se
retrouve avec une filière industrielle
qui essaie de trouver des solutions
qui selon les écologistes outre ne sont
pas la bonne solution qu'est ce qu'on
fait à très très court terme on a les
piscines blindés y est ce qu'on
recherchait d'autres piscines est ce qu
on fait un gros trou est ce qu'on va les
mines est-ce qu'on est ce qu'on fait
quelque chose
à très court terme déjà c'est pas si
c'est aussi jose à apprendre 50 ans de
chantier fins d'entreposage et c'est
donc ce n'est pas une solution à court
terme
soit un cortège s'est renforcé les
piscines pour qu'elles soient plus
sécurisé c'est en construire une
nouvelle mais là il ya des gros débat
aussi qui se posent à la hague en ce
moment avec une consultation qui est
très très controversée et en accueille
même auprès des syndicats qui est assez
mitigé cette piscine
aura nos va probablement proposer en
entreposage à sec en ce qu'on nous
demande greenpeace depuis des décennies
qui empêchera de retraiter le
combustible en question
ce qui sera à priori impropre à être
retraité facilement
parce qu'en fait les piscines arrivera à
saturation avant que la nouvelle serait
mise en service même si tout va bien
donc en fait on voit que l'industrie
nucléaire fille nucléaire française et
notamment aux anneaux essaye de de
rafistoler comme ça pour essayer de
faire coller les échéances les unes avec
les autres mais que globalement ça va
assez mal mais il rafistole parce que il
ya eu des opposants dont greenpeace qui
se sont opposés au stockage profond
pendant des années avec beaucoup de
vigueur et en réalité on aurait lancé
c'est ce système il ya une dizaine
d'années on aurait quelque chose qui
serait totalement lisse on va avoir une
bosse on va avoir du stockage qui sera à
sec effectivement à cause de ça mais on
va la résorber et c'est le meilleur
moyen de
finalement de faire en sorte qu'on gère
l'ensemble des déchets et ça n'empêche
absolument pas ça n'a aucune incidence
sur la trajectoire de décarbonation par
ailleurs
j'ai vu passer quelque chose je vais
vous lire sur le chat que pensez-vous
des essais nucléaires du fort de vaux
jour couverts par le secret défense a
donné lieu alors selon la personne qui
pose la question c'est a donné lieu à ce
qu'on appelle aujourd'hui la rue des
cancers et entendu parler de ça mais
toutes ces choses là sont condamnables
tenir on doit avoir la transparence on
doit avoir un haut niveau de sécurité et
lorsque on sort de ça les clous et qu'on
essaie de cacher des choses c'est
inacceptable et s'il ya bien une chose
que dont je suis reconnaissant aux
écologistes anti nucléaires et à
greenpeace c'est finalement quand même
de faire en sorte qu'on y est une
industrie qui soit extrêmement
extrêmement
précautionneuse au principe de
précaution est érigé en point absolument
essentiel ce qui fait qu'aujourd'hui on
arrête d'être ans je pense que on serait
il ya 40 ans mais on entendrait ni
parler de ces de ces fissures et on
aurait pas d'arrêt de tranche on serait
ya 40 ans il aura hélas gendarmes et au
fait si non qui est de proximité les
services par ailleurs là donc on est
dans les normes a déjà fait ça pour les
écologistes il n'avait pas créé comment
il appelait sa rente ares athéna non
c'était quoi le groupe de gens mais
oui il y avait eu un groupe qui a été
chargée de surveiller les écoles jerman
a bien défendu on estime à tort sur
l'agriculture ou à l'agriculture
l'émetteur délétère d'émetteurs
question internet des questions sur les
sur les centrales à sel fondu et
pourquoi après un
doctorat sur la fusion est il devenu
anti nucléaire c'est pas viable
alors la fusion est celle fondée sa part
la même chose je sais pas je lui la
question est qui sont chaudes et son
train là c'est le fond du ca ses deux
fils et c'est le fond dit ouais ça de la
fission c'est de la quatrième génération
s'est notamment les filières au thorium
qui sont imaginés potentiellement un
jour en chine
c'est une alternative aux à l'uranium
mais on est encore sur des réacteurs qui
vont peut-être voir le jour dans dix
vingt ans
pour moi ça change pas fondamentalement
le le potentiel du nucléaire à l'échelle
mondiale puisque les contraintes sont
les mêmes c'est des gros réacteur alors
je pense peut-être faire des smr à sels
fondus aussi mais
pour l'instant on est sur les mêmes
problématiques en termes de
massification et de potentiel très
limité de décarbonation que que les
filières de fission à l'uranium alors en
tête de profession
elles sont exposées donc on a cinquante
six centrales sur le territoire
l'algérie n'ont que monsieur poutine
près de lydie de nous faire une petite
pichenette quitte pas
c'est un programme qui a été qui a été
pensée où il n'y avait pas trop la
guerre en europe il n'y avait pas trop
de terrorisme
vraiment vénère vénère
la sécurité des centrales gilles c est
ce qu il ya des missiles qui pourrait
protéger nos centrales est ce qu'il ya
des gendarmes formés à l'utilisation
stinger ou de gros talent je pense que
tu espères que moi là dessus que je
pourrais faire observer c'est que quand
on a construit le père l'une des
caractéristiques mais pas la seule que
l'on a souhaité y mettre c'est une
sécurité extrêmement renforcer et donc
avant on avait une double coque c'était
très compliqué dans le premier repère de
flamanville à construire on va passer
dans le père de nouvelle génération sur
une simple coque mais l'idée c'est que
ça résiste aux chocs d'un avion alors on
sait pas quel avion temps culte et ouais
on sait pas c'est s'est classé secret
défense
on considère que c'est probablement un
avion de ligne mais il n'y a pas eu de
diffusion d'informations à cet égard et
puis par ailleurs on a mis quelque chose
qui est aussi une innovation c'est que
sous le réacteur il ya un cendrier qui
est black hawk est là pour récupérer la
galette de cause du corium c'est ça on a
vu où on a vu le bordel que ça fukushima
elle cendrier il a pas l'air très
efficace
bas malgré tout ils apprendront éviter
d'avoir de très grandes quantités de
radioéléments dans la nature pour
l'instant
le site aujourd'hui est sous contrôle
objectivement c'est tous les experts
sérieux le dise quoi il n'ya pas de
rayonnement il n'y a pas eu un seul mort
il ya eu un mort reconnu par la justice
et c'est contester le fait que qu'il ya
eu des morts du fait qu on a eu un
tsunami ni vaincu non mais mais on
évacue par précaution l'accueil qui a eu
une mort aussi oui c'est mais si on
ramène le nombre de mort de la filière
nucléaire à l'énergie produite on est à
peu près au même niveau que les gens qui
tombent des éoliennes voilà on est de
cet ordre là en réalité mais si je
ramène ça je le compare avec les
énergies carbonées là je suis mille fois
continue né au yen qui tombe bon ça va
faire chier le fermier du coin quand il
y en a une mais qui meurt en installant
les éoliennes en raison malheureusement
mais dramatiquement c'est un tout petit
mais oui mais c'est en fait c'est
spectaculaire quand il ya un accident
nucléaire gilles ça fait peut-être 7000
morts dans le cas
de tchernobyl et 0 ou 1 dans le cas de
fukushima donc les
les plans d'évacuation de fukushima ont
fonctionné ouais ça a plutôt bien
fonctionné quelques crises cardiaques
parce que les gens étaient des plaies si
c'est ça c'est ça vingt mille morts du
fait du tsunami d'accord mais on évacue
quand même beaucoup oui maintenant les
gens veulent plus revenir on peut
laisser les gens revenir dans certaines
zones et les gens ne reviennent pas
deux cent mille évacuer je crois
réfugiés qui effectivement une moins un
sixième 50 minutes qui était parvenu
huit ans après en 2019 je n'ai pas les
chiffres aujourd'hui pour différentes
raisons parce qu'ils ont refait leur vie
mais aussi certains avaient peur de
revenir
fukushima c'est aussi une facture de 200
milliards d'euros et ça ça a un coût
social aussi important c'est de l'argent
qui peut pas être investies ailleurs et
notamment dans la transition énergétique
quand il ya eu fukushima le japon a
décidé d'arrêter la plupart de ses
réacteurs nucléaires pour avoir
d'électricité ils ont mis en place une
politique d'économie d'énergie qui a
plutôt bien fonctionné mais surtout ils
ont construit à la va vite des centrales
fossiles qui elle du coup on y
énormément etc si en france demain il y
avait un accident nucléaire majeur ce
qu'on ne peut pas écarter évidemment on
ne souhaite pas ce serait des centaines
de milliards d'euros qui seraient perdus
et on perdrait probablement au moins 10
ans dans la transition énergétique parce
que c'est parce que ce sera la priorité
absolue et ça se comprend donc il ya la
question du nombre de morts est en fait
qu'on parle du vin ou de 7000 morts on
parle du nombre de morts de réalisation
et sur tchernobyl les chiffres vont du
simple au x 20 il ya un peu de tout
après il ya tous les morts chien direct
des fiches de vichy les chiffres
aujourd'hui sont à peu près unanime tous
les organismes sérieux situe le nombre
de morts entre 5 et 7 mais c'est quoi
c'est quoi un organisme pas sérieux
c'est l'om est par exemple un organisme
s'il ya un organisme qui a parlé de 40
mille morts
et qui est un organe us qui affiliés un
mouvement écologique qui je crois est
proche de vous en russie voilà et c'est
ce rapport a été très largement
critiquée pour sa méthodologie la
réalité c'est que on était quand même en
période du razès la transparence sur
tout ce qui s'est passé est quand même
assez difficile à avoir alors
effectivement il ya probablement pas eu
10 millions de morts etc mais le chiffre
exact c'est quand même assez difficile
de se prononcer dessus il ya au moins
effectivement dix mille morts à peu près
mais c'est quand même assez difficile et
assez incertain ce qui dit aussi si oui
après lui ok ok imaginons qu'on ait eu
dix mille morts ça reste quand même
rapporté à la quantité d'énergie
nucléaire produit dans le monde une
énergie extrêmement sûr extrêmement
efficace voilà et puis j'ajoute que les
plans de transition par les nerfs
aujourd'hui nous met dans la panade
parce qu'on est obligé d'importer en
urgence du gaz d'endroits qui ne sont
pas la russie et que l'on re débarder
chantera à charbon et qu'encore une fois
le foisonnement ça n'existe pas c'est à
dire le fait d'aller chercher de
l'énergie à gibraltar
quand il ya du vent là bas et que j'en
ai besoin à paris ça ça n'existe pas il
n'y a pas de modèle qui permet de faire
fonctionner sa et le stockage est bien
le stockage c'est absolument hors de
prix environnementalement et
économiquement
déjà quand on parle du gaz il faut
savoir de quoi on parle en europe le gaz
est utilisé pour trois usages presqu'à
égalité
un peu plus d'un tiers la production
d'électricité dont on parle
exclusivement en france le chauffage est
un peu mon entière l'industrie donc on
fait une focalisation sur
l'électricité en france on sait très
bien pourquoi parce qu'on avait cette
obsession pour le nucléaire mais la
question du gaz elle est bien plus large
que la question de la production
d'électricité
la réalité c'est que si aujourd'hui on
n'avait pas développé massivement les
nerfs en europe on aurait encore plus
besoin d'importer du gaz un peu partout
dans le monde on a encore plus de
problèmes d'approvisionnement et on
aurait encore plus d'émissions de gaz à
effet serre ça c'est indéniable si on
avait utilisé l'argent qu'on a mis dans
un zoo nerfs dans le nucléaire on serait
totalement autonome parce que je sers ne
serait toujours pas un service ben ok on
aurait d un effet de série qui aurait
joué on aurait certainement beaucoup de
2 p r qui serait sur le point de l'être
on n'aurait pas abandonné la filière on
aurait continué à construire des repères
depuis 20 ans on serait aujourd'hui
quasiment
autonome de toutes énergies carbonées
moi je pense que si la france n'est
justement pas fait le choix de le père
il ya vingt ans j'ai fait le choix
d'investir massivement dans les énergies
renouvelables seraient l'électrique et
de chaleur on aurait une empreinte
carbone qui sera aujourd'hui beaucoup
moins dans 20 milliards de dépenses
juste les montants qui sont déjà engagés
dans l'est dans les yeux nerfs je pense
que tu es d'accord à peu près sur ce
chiffre non non ça c'est jusqu'à 2030
cinquième semble à non non non c'est 200
milliards jusqu'à 2035 on est aux
alentours de 120 milliards de dépenses
le prc 23 milliards voilà donc c'est pas
en rajoutant 23 milliards qui sont à
changer quoi que ce soit les allemands
sont à 450 milliards ils ont failli
souffler ils sont il va bien ils sont
complètement plantés et aujourd'hui il
commence à y avoir un début de débat sur
le fait de pas fermer les centrales
nucléaires qui leur reste et c'est la
même chose si je prends les danois si je
prends même les espagnols
on a à peu près les mêmes scénarios
cirque on ne voit pas le moment où
durablement on va réussir à pouvoir
s'affranchir des énergies carbonées il
faut des systèmes de stockage et c'est
des systèmes de stockage qui vont être
extrêmement difficile à mettre en oeuvre
alors énergies renouvelables et
dépendance à la chine aux technologies
chinoises aux terres rares chinoises
tout ça ça pose un problème
géopolitiquement parlant d'un est ce
qu'on préfère être dépens des russes ou
des chinois ou deux personnes
les terrasses n'est pas tellement un
problème sont pas ça fait juste des gros
trous donatienne surtout pour les
éoliennes en mer en fait le néodyme
notamment le reste c'est assez marginal
après il ya des enjeux de certains
matériaux qui deviennent critiques alors
pas forcément en termes de réserves mais
plutôt en termes de flux et certains
régions du monde comme la chine où
aujourd'hui sont les principaux
producteurs c'est pas le cas de tous les
tous les matériaux par exemple le
lithium qui est bine composante
essentielle pour décarbonés la mobilité
notamment il ya les principales réserves
croissance en amérique du sud donc il ya
différentes sources d'approvisionnement
qui sont possibles après effectivement
on a une dépendance à la chine qui pose
question notamment parce que parce que
la chine est en situation très tendue
notamment avec taïwan en ce moment il
pourrait pourrait avoir un emballement
aussi avec les états unis là dedans donc
il ya vraiment un potentiel de conflit
géopolitique pour autant dimanche il
vous dit que c'est tout chemin de mort
ça annonce la couleur pour autant une
fois qu'on a apporté sa matière première
est qu'on a installé les éoliennes et
les panneaux solaires etc il ya plus
besoin d'importer ce qui est important
c'est de réussir à déployer suffisamment
et après de mettre en place des filières
de stockage et puis après ils m'ont tous
ceux qui aiment commando cycle ouais bah
en fait ça se recycle assez bien les
vannes 0 ce sera aussi l epal alors il
ya une pâle qui était un prototype de
pales qui a été fait 100% recyclable
aujourd'hui les pales on les valorise on
en fait d'énergie on les brûle pour
faire du général les auteurs non non il
ya qu aux états unis qui sont eux qui
sont enterrés il ya encore une fois et
en fait on aura beau c'est totalement
interdit d intérêts en france la
deuxième à terre le monde et comment est
ce qu'on fait du radier qu'on met sous
une éolienne en béton en france est
obligatoire maintenant de l'enlever en
totalise les provisions ou les locaux il
est pris en compte dans mais non il est
pas prêt en 50i
c'est ça cinquante mille euros de
chiffre exact est absolument insuffisant
serre que les tests qui ont été faites
des montants demandés aux lianes plutôt
aux alentours des 2 300 euros non il ya
un parquet qui a été démantelée
récemment qu'ils avaient tous trois cent
mille ou par et oui par éolienne et pas
en france mais l'approvisionnement c'est
paris moyenne aussi mais il ya un il ya
un démantèlement qui a eu lieu à s'est
récemment en france pour faire du report
mangue c'est-à-dire de enlever les
éoliennes existantes dernier compris le
socle non y compris le solde pour mettre
des plus puissantes donc avec en soit le
plus profond parce que sinon ça tient
pas et en fait c'était dans les coûts
estimés la réalité c'est que les
opérateurs d'éoliennes ce sont des
bilans qui sont généralement extrêmement
fragile et que il dépose le bilan et qui
a personne pour aller chercher ça quand
il dépose le bilan voilà donc c'est une
fois qu'ils ont amorti le truc anti
rentrer dans cette notion
d'investissement pour le moment on n'a
pas créé le dispositif d'assurance qui
permettent de s'assurer que on va aller
faire c'était mentalement de façon
efficace c'est vraiment du fantasme il
n'y a aucune éolienne en france qui n'a
pas été démantelé ou qui est mais on a
l'expérience ja se passe à l'étranger
n'ont pas une carrière aux états unis en
particulier ses systèmes alimentation
n'est pas la même en france les agathois
ouais mais comme comment on fait quand
quelqu'un dépose le bilan cyril à
autonomiser ses parcs comment on fait
pour éviter ça et approvisionnement qui
est né à sac est suffisant ok mais la
réglementation pour le monde il faut lui
falloir s'assurer que ça fonctionne
c'est à mon avis beaucoup plus
sérieusement fait pour le nucléaire que
pour les légionnaires à aujourd'hui et
puis j'ajoute que la lame la séquence
ont poliment ouais mais la quantité de
déchets est incomparablement supérieur
rapporté à l'énergie c'est dix fois
supérieur j'ai le visuel dans mon sac
est arrivé sur wayne j'aurais dû le
sortir j'ai pas pensé à le sortir ça
fait enfin la quantité de produits de
métaux rapporté à l'énergie
la densité en fait énergétique elle est
dix fois supérieur par rapport aux
honneurs dans le cas du nucléaire
nicolas encore la réalité c'est que le
béton d'éoliennes la cdo liane il va
être recyclé le béton on peut en
fabriquer des routes ou des pistes
cyclables assez facilement ça ça ça
existe déjà aujourd'hui donc c'est
réutilisables le béton ou l'acier des
centrales nucléaires il sera jamais
réutilisé parce qu'il est radioactif et
parce qu'il sera en gros traité comme un
déchet le différend qui refonde parce
que ce sont des niveaux de radioactivité
qui sont extrêmement faibles il ya que
le coeur si je prends la quantité de
déchets ultimes qui sont de forte
activité c'est 1800 mètres carrés c'est
en gros un cube de je crois qu'un maître
d'art est à peu près voilà c'est ça la
totalité de déchets qu'on a produit pour
l'instant qu'ils sont de forte activité
et la très très grande majorité des
déchets que produit une centrale
nucléaire ce ne sont pas des déchets
radioactifs les chèques on peut
réutiliser comme dans le ce 228 ou les
machines
coup puis les couples je sais pas quel
pourcentage mais je pense que la vaste
majorité de sonepar radioactifs non ils
sont radioactifs cd durée de vie qui
sont courtes s'il faut je crois que
c'est trente ans qu'on appelle des
déchets à des courtes ils sont il faut
durer plusieurs durées de vie pour 2010
pour pouvoir après les réutiliser un
jour peut-être mais en fait aujourd'hui
non c'est pas les gérer il faut les
stocker ils sont moins radioactifs ils
sont trois à quatre fois moins
radioactif que le
comment s'appelle cette pierre bretonne
le granit breton voilà donc ça donne une
idée c'est beaucoup plus dangereux de se
balader dans du granit breton que dans
des déchets d'une centrale nucléaire
vous y quand même ça non je parle de la
vaste majorité des déchets qui ne sont
pas exposés aux rayonnements
non mais c'est ce que je dis c'est
factuel enfin je les lui dans les
documents qui m'ont permis de préparer
cette émission est ce que vous avez déjà
leur passé l'un comme l'autre
là où il stocke les déchets où il
entrepose
alors greenpeace n'est pas du week-end
filles c'est vrai sens et le visiter je
suis passé au tour mais je ne suis pas
rentrer à l'intérieur j'ai fait le tour
de la haye mais je suis pas encore
rentré à l'intérieur
et l'andra j'ai pas encore visité mais
peut-être un jour
question
les voitures électriques
c'est encore un gros push it de
politique après moi le déluge c'est une
véritable transition c'est un vrai faux
problème ça va devenir un problème c'est
un eldorado qu'on fait miroiter tout le
monde mais que personne ne touchera à ce
que ça coûtera trop cher et puis on va
passer de terreur de l'icm et de
matières premières donc les voitures
électriques c'est bien pour la
transition écologique c'est pas bien
c'est simplement pour reporter les
maladies pulmonaires ailleurs
c'est de la délocalisation de pollution
c'est quoi
alors la voiture électrique c'est une
partie de la solution mais c'est surtout
pas la solution qui permettra de
décarbonée seul le transport pourquoi
parce que justement il ya des besoins en
matériaux qui sont immenses
les laisse pas les stocks mais en tout
cas les flux de lui comme les
productions de l'islam qui est prévu
dans les prochaines décennies nous
pourrons pas au niveau mondial de
subvenir aux besoins en lithium pour la
voiture électrique individuel et en tout
cas donc c'est une des solutions mais ça
va de pair avec quelque chose qui est
indispensable c'est la sobriété sur les
véhicules individuels ou c'est-à-dire au
lieu d'avoir des véhicules de deux
tonnes faire des véhicules beaucoup plus
léger qui vont demander du coût des
batteries moins puissantes et consommer
moins d'énergie et de matériaux mais
c'est aussi développer des vraies
solutions alternatives à la voiture
individuelle de transport en commun de
vélos électriques et c'est sûr qu'ils
vont avec en termes de réseaux
ferroviaires et cyclable
d'accord avec nicolas la voiture c'est
un système qui est un système assez
aberrant une voiture ça fonctionne 6 %
du temps et dans ces six pour cent il ya
un pour cent du temps qui est des
embouteillages ou chercher des places de
parking et un seul de dons et il ya tant
à l'échelle mondiale il ya 1,1 passagers
par véhicule voilà et on transporte
effectivement une tonne 4 donc c'est
quelque chose qui est aberrant et qui
mérite d'être pensé alors il y a à ce
nombre d'évolutions technologiques qui
vont permettre de faire ça il ya l'idée
de carsharing carpooling carsharing
c'est quand je
je monte dans une voiture partage voilà
une norme et je monte je suis tout seul
je monte dans une voiture je paye pour
le temps que je l'utilisé
et puis carpooling c'est quand je fais
du blabla car
voilà et donc c'est quand on observe ces
modèles on s'aperçoit que ça peut faire
évoluer les taux de charge de façon
assez significative
et puis il ya quelque chose qui pourrait
arriver qui serait de nature à
transformer quand même pas mal le modèle
c'est le véhicule autonome on pense que
si le véhicule autonome arrive plus
personne ne sera propriétaire de sa
voiture enfin très long terme
perspective de long terme et que l'on
démultipliera les taux de charge on
n'est pas sera probablement entre 20 et
30%
voilà pour tout faire comme un cubain y
rendre obligatoire le fait de prendre
des auto stoppeurs
je je je sais pas les modèles qui sont
des modèles directif place jamais
beaucoup mais en tout cas il faut bien
considérer qu' il ya eu une forme d'âge
d'or de l'automobile et qu'il faut
essayer de repenser les modèles alors il
faut faire très attention parce que
quand on est des citadins bas on n'a pas
besoin de voiture on entend ce à dire il
faut arrêter la voiture et c est en
réalité il ya 80 90 % des français qui
ont besoin d'une voiture au moins une
fois par semaine et donc il faut se
méfier des gens qui souvent ont le
pouvoir médiatique et parfois politiques
qui sont pas du tout c'est le phénomène
gilet jaune qui ne comprennent pas ce
qui se passe dans les territoires
et donc il faut continuer à penser des
solutions à base de voiture mais je
crois que ce qui est important c'est de
créer des feuilles de route pour que ces
solutions finalement elles soient
compatibles avec
finalement des feuilles de décarbonation
qui fonctionne donc carpooling car
sharing et puis à terme effectivement
véhicule autonome avec des taux de
charges qui augmentent fortement
est ce que le véhicule autonome c'est
pas un peu
on fait encore hier où étaient les
voitures volantes des choses comme ça
ce qui est sûr c'est que on en est quand
même assez loin même s'il ya des
prototypes qui existent ici ou là la
question qui se pose c'est comment on va
réussir à faire rouler à la fois des
véhicules autonomes et des véhicules qui
sont conduits par les humains parce que
en fait s'il avait que des véhicules
autonomes ce serait beaucoup plus simple
il suffirait de faire communiquer les
véhicules entre eux et et il n'y aurait
pas le facteur humain donc c'est toute
cette période de transition qui est qui
est compliqué mais moi j'en suis quand
même sur le fait que avoir des véhicules
autonomes 6 et des véhicules même
électrique de 2 tonnes pour transporter
une personne ça n'a pas grand sens même
s'ils augmentent effectivement le taux
d'utilisation
le taux d'utilisation c'est ça reste
quand même assez grotesque je trouve et
on pourrait faire la même chose avec des
véhicules beaucoup plus léger
et qui poseraient pas forcément moins de
problèmes de sur de sécurité puisque
puisque il y aurait les mêmes
dispositifs de sécurité
question internet les russes pensaient
que le réacteur était safe les japonais
disait que les tsunamis de plus de 5,7 m
ça n'existait pas chez eux
pourquoi on pense qu'un trou dans le sol
ça ne risque rien d'abord les russes
pensaient que le réacteur était safe
c'est pas vrai les réacteurs
russes c'était un objet de préoccupation
et particulièrement les modèles de
tchernobyl qui ont été des commissionné
rapidement par la suite de cet accident
quant à fukushima il était le régulateur
qui n'avaient pas le régulateur français
qui a fait beaucoup moins de pouvoir que
le régulateur français avait demandé à
trois reprises qu'on construise une
digue de je crois 10 ou 12 mètres qui
n'a pas été construite et qui aurait
évité ce qui s'est passé si elle avait
été
à cet égard je pense que voilà ça montre
bien l'importance d'avoir des
régulateurs fort et la france est prise
en exemple par les pays nucléaires pour
l'acsa greenpeace voilà grâce à
greenpeace pour la qualité de ce son
régulateur
le japon aussi était l'un des exemples
avant fukushima comme avec la france
l'un des pays les plus sûrs et l'autre
point que je veux dire c'est que en fait
la sûreté des réacteurs nucléaires
actuelles est basé sur des modèles qui
essaye d'évaluer le risque sans tonale
dont on comprend en gros la tempête sans
tonale la plus important on rajoute une
petite marge et on fait en sorte que la
centrale actuelle la centrale résiste à
cet événement avec le réchauffement
climatique se pose la question de
comment va être modifié cette
catastrophe sans tonale quelle fréquence
et quelle amplitude parce que en fait il
ya un certain nombre d'événements
qui pourrait être d'ampleur beaucoup
plus importante que ce qu'on a connu par
le passé on se dirige vers un climat qui
est quand même un certain on a à d voilà
des intempéries qui peuvent être
inédit qu'on n'a jamais connu même dans
les remontées à des archives même très
très hypothétique donc ça a posé la
question de est ce que la sûreté des
réacteurs actuels et adaptée à
l'évolution des catastrophes naturelles
en temps de réchauffement climatique
personnellement je n'ai pas la réponse
j'espère que oui mais on n'est pas à
l'abri d'une catastrophe naturelle de
grande ampleur arrive en france et un
impact sur la sûreté des réacteurs
toute chose à un risque par définition
et la marge de réserve elle augmente
régulièrement je l' ai dit tout à
l'heure c'est à dire que on mais
on fait évoluer la réglementation
des réacteurs français ce qui n'est pas
le cas aux états unis où pour autant il
ya eu three miles island mais il n'y a
pas eu d'autres accidents il ya comme en
france d'ailleurs des des accidents
sérieux baisse
de décennie en décennie
voilà j'observe que en ce qui concerne
les incidents extrêmes là sur les
réseaux sociaux il y avait pas mal de
fautes ou qui circulait alors c'est plus
du domaine de l'anecdote mais d'un parc
solaire qui a été détruit par la neige
qui s'est pris une très lente je sais
pas où ces tests et au chili il me
semble un très grandes quantités de
neige et qui a été totalement lessivé de
ce fait donc ça c'est valable aussi même
si c'est pas les mêmes niveaux de risque
dans d'autre sens que
pensez-vous des travaux du physicien
gérard mourou qui espère avec la
technologie du laser réduire la durée de
vie des déchets nucléaires d'un million
d'années à 30 minutes
oui en théorie c'est possible là je
pense que c'est plus un physicien qui
serait répondra à ces choses-là jeu
d'une façon générale il faut encourager
la recherche après est ce que c'est
quelque chose d'industriels ou dans une
perspective de temps raisonnable je suis
pas capable d'en juger on n'est pas du
tout à gagner opposé à la recherche
fondamentale sur ces sujets sur ce qu'on
peut dire là dessus c'est que pour
l'instant ça reste théoriquement
possible mais très hypothétique et
surtout à priori la besoins énergétiques
pour générer la puissance nécessaire en
termes de lasers serait largement
supérieur à toute l'énergie qui a été
générée par cette quantité de
combustible
la quantité de déchets aujourd'hui
à priori après on n'est pas à l'abri
d'une bonne évolution à l'avenir s'il
faut construire un réacteur derrière
chaque laser ça va plus les questions
internet at-on une estimation des
populations animales touché par
fukushima l'accident de fukushima
on dit souvent que tient en oublie les
fukushima sont des réacteurs et des
parts dans des réserves à des réservoirs
la diversité écologique mal formulée
différemment le acteur quand il pète ça
fait dégager les sommes donc les animaux
revivre qu'il ment et est en fait je
sais pas pour fukushima mais en tout cas
pour tchernobyl c'est devenu une zone
d'observation où les gens viennent de
loin pour voir le comportement des
animaux il ya tout un tas d'espèces qui
n'avait qu qui avait complètement
disparu qui se sont extrêmement bien
développer dans cette zone qui doivent
me semble que c'est un rayon de 30
kilomètres je suis pas sûr c'est plus
grand en tout cas que avant avant ça
avant que les petits lapins de
blanche-neige convient de faire des
petits terriers est ce qu'il ya eu une
étude sur les cancers des passereaux
est-ce que la radioactivité s'est
déplacé dans les plumes est-ce que les
sangliers radioactifs c'est une légende
non j'en sais rien moi ce que je sais
c'est que effectivement les notamment
les gros mammifères et même faire moyens
sont revenus à tchernobyl par contre il
me semble qu'il ya des études qui ont
montré qu'ils avaient des déclins de
populations d'insectes de petits
insectes et de petits oiseaux encore
aujourd'hui donc la biodiversité n'est
pas revenu n'est pas foisonnante dans
pour toutes les espèces
c'est un commentaire mais qui est qui
est valable qui n'est pas sensé dans la
session questions donc thomas ont valu
tirer l'oreille l'exploitation des mines
de charbon en allemagne à évacuer la
population sur une surface plus grande
que les zones d'exclusion de fukushima
transition ratée là on va partir sur un
autre sujet sujets économiques et donc
je vous fais pas le dessein de on est un
petit peu dans la panade
que notre société occidentale
base sa croissance jeanne consommation
énergétique
va dire exponentielle européenne
européenne le scénario c'est un scénario
de croissance oui on se remet à sion est
en décroissance ou récession n'ont enfin
pas de décroissance économique mais de
décroissance d'utilisation d'énergies
primaires oui alors l'énergie première
quand elles baissent en général on se
tape des récessions et
enfin les scénarios du giec
partouche du principe que on va pas
consommer plus d'énergie qu'aujourd'hui
nommé le génie font les juifs ont même
été où ils font pas l'économie a dit oui
non je parle en europe ouais après la
question c'est la délocalisation de
notre consommation d'énergie avec donc
de notre pollution aussi
donc à votre avis est-ce qu' on reste
sur le nucléaire ont fait un mix
énergétique
résille on résiste ont
endurci avec de nerfs avec du nucléaire
avec peut-être encore un peu du charbon
est encore
pétrole ou et du tout c'est comme
maintenant c'est comme manon là on a la
même consommation d'un mix énergétique
on est toujours à 80% de pétrole connaît
30 ans donc c'est que maintenant je
connais pas le mix total je connais le
mix électrique entre guillemets
et le mix électrique il est très très
très décarbonés en france en ce qu'on
éclaire parce qu'on a le nucléaire et
voilà on a on a une feuille de route
pour arriver à décarbonés assez bien en
devait d'ailleurs
si flamanville avait été livrée sortir
du du charbon voilà donc il ya quand
même un scénario si
[Musique]
on a une filière nucléaire qui s'
industrie est industriel ou ont des
carbone de façon efficace et ont
d'autres pays peuvent
aller dans ce sens également alors que
les scénarios à base de nerfs sont
beaucoup plus coûteux sensiblement plus
coûteux et encore une fois il ya
l'hypothèse du stockage qui n'est pas
résolu à part les pays qui peuvent se
construire des steppes alors un accident
type
tchernobyl ou à peu près du même genre
c'est combien de milliards de rousse et
ses 200 milliards
enfin il ya des estimations très
variable c'est entre 60 et de ce que
j'ai lu 250 milliards
quand il ya une zone de conflit qui
commence à s'approcher d'un réacteur
nucléaire c'est bien compliqué non
on a le cas actuellement on a le cas
actuellement et
pour l'instant les russes quoi qu'on en
pense moi je ne pense pas beaucoup de
bien on était quand même responsable
c'est à dire qu'ils ont laissé je reste
simple sur les deux centrales nucléaires
dont une qui ne fonctionne plus qu'à
tchernobyl sur laquelle ils sont entrés
ils ont laissé les opérateurs écrit bien
faire leur travail
qu'ils ont été responsables puisqu'ils
ont quand même commis des crimes de
guerre et des crimes de terrorisme
rentrer dans une centrale nucléaire
c'est un crime de guerre moi j'ai suivi
en direct à quatre heures du matin en
fin de 2 à 4 heures du matin avec une
webcam qui était sur le toit de la
centrale de sanaa pour dire ça pour idia
pardon en ukraine l'arrivée des chars et
des troupes russes qui tirait on savait
pas trop où etc c'était un peu anxiogène
évidemment alors évidemment on va dire
que les réussir avec ou
alors il ya eu des obus mais a priori
pas sur le pas sur le réacteur en tout
cas c'est difficile à prouver et après
eu des tirs sur un bâtiment où il y
avait des troupes ukrainienne qui était
limitrophes au réacteur ce qui est sûr
c'est que évidemment on va dire que
poutine n'aura pas n'aurait pas
d'intérêt à tirer un missile directement
sur la centrale ça paraît très fou après
on est peut-être à l'abri de rien avec
lui après se poser la question de
l'accident aussi c'est à dire que il ya
s'est récemment je crois ya une semaine
un missile qui a survolé à quelques
dizaines de mètres au dessus de la
centrale parce qu'il allait plus loin il
est plus loin un tir raté ça arrive les
conséquences de une chute de missiles
sur un réacteur nucléaire c'est assez
inconnu
et pour rejoindre la discussion sur la
centrale solaire qui étaient enneigées
j'ai vu récemment une photo d'une
centrale solaire en ukraine qui s'était
pris en missiles il ya jeu pas moins une
trentaine de panneaux solaires qui sont
foutus et qu'il faudra peut-être trois
mois à remplacer si jamais on n'était
pas en temps de guerre civile où les
offres si ça arrivait sur une centrale
nucléaire je pense que les conséquences
seraient pas les mêmes alors évidemment
c'est très hypothétique on n'est à
l'abri de rien et voilà est-ce qu'en
france on est sûr que dans les 80
prochaines années on va pas avoir de
conflit armé c'est une question qui est
difficile c'est vivre ça expose au
risque de mourir un moment et par
ailleurs on n'a pas parlé tellement
de la la balance économique des
différentes filières c'est la filière
vénère qui est massivement apporté
plusieurs études à cet égard un panneau
solaire c'est quasiment aujourd'hui du
100%
pratiquement plus de fabricants de
talent de panneaux solaires qui sont
capables de faire du gros volumes en
europe et les éoliennes on est en train
d'essayer péniblement de construire une
filière mais à l'intérieur les sous
composants sont importés donc de l'ordre
de 65 70 % c'est quand même très
significative donc c'est le bilan de
cette affaire c'est un bilan où
finalement on a une énergie qui n'est
pas disponible quand on le veut on a des
coûts de connexion dont on ne parle
absolument jamais mais qui sont
extrêmement significative par centrale
ça induit des quantités de cuivre qui
sont extrêmement importantes et on
oublie de parler de la rareté de cette
ressource qui est quand même assez
importante également et puis le bilan
économique c'est un bilan qui est
désastreux parce que vous avez que les
gens qui font des emplois de maintenance
à faible valeur ajoutée c'est pas des
techniciens très forte valeur ajoutée
comme on peut en trouver dans le monde
du nucléaire et ce sont des produits qui
sont pour l'essentiel importé et une
grande partie des importations d'asie du
sud est
la réalité si on a pas de filière
industrielle en france c'est aussi parce
qu edf a fait le choix de se tourner
vers le nucléaire et à freiner l'essor
de des filières renouvelables en france
là ils commencent à s'y mettre il ya des
projets en europe y compris en france 2
de panneaux solaires à quasiment 1 giga
annuel ça commence à être des volumes
intéressants qu'il faut encourager on
est sur l'éolien flottant par exemple
plutôt bien passé d'un point de vue
industriel on n'est pas remis d'un point
de vue c c'est quand même une industrie
assez technique on est quand même bien
placé là dessus la question du soin
c'est enfin on à la question c'est
vraiment qu'on a le choix entre investir
continuer à investir dans le nucléaire
ou investir dans les filières
renouvelables et sur le prix moi je suis
pas du tout d'accord en fait on traverse
une crise énergétique majeure tout ce
qui est investi sur l'éolien sur une
crise
grand longue
une crise puissant choc potentiellement
gazier
là en ce moment les renouvelables ça
rapporte de l'argent l'éolien ça
rapporte énormément d'argent à l'état si
les prix l'énergie continuent à être
aussi élevé d'ici à 2024 l'état aura été
remboursé de tout ce qu'il a investi
dans l'éolien alors sur le
photovoltaïque c'est bien entendu les
gens vont adorer si les prix restent à
ce niveau là malheureusement c'est ce
qui semble se dessiner et justement
développer les énergies renouvelables
aujourd'hui en urgence et les économies
d'énergie c'est ça qui va permettre de
limiter la facture alors le commentaire
de gilles était très vrai en termes de
coûts énergétiques
est-ce qu'il va falloir faire du nuc les
goûts et des zones et ragoût pour
maintenir un prix suffisamment
acceptable pour le développement de la
population dont la consommation et j'en
viens à la question d'internet qui dit
faut-il également passé par de la
décroissance ou bien du nucléaire ou
est-ce que le nucléaire est bien
suffisant quid de la sobriété d'abord
sur le prix je pense que c'est important
de le dire le prix tel qu'il existe
aujourd'hui c'est un prix artificielle
sûr que quand on dit c'est 40 euros le
mégawattheure pour les zones à des
constructions et ainsi de suite non
c'est pas ça c'est que on dit au
priorise absolument cette énergie devant
tout autre c'est à dire que si tout à
coup il ya un peu de vent on dit aux
gens qui font du nucléaire écoutez vous
pouvez nous vendre l'énergie au prix que
vous voulez on n'en veut pas parce qu'on
veut tout acheter aux gens qu'ils font
des nerfs pour les aider à se financer
c'est comme ça que le modèle est
construit et pas autrement donc on
priorise cette énergie sur tout autre et
donc en réalité si on disait en fait
c'est le prix de marché plus le prix du
carbone et tout le monde est à l'inégal
il n'y aurait pas de l'anr voilà c'est
quelque chose qui mérite d'être dit
parce que le prix des nerfs tel qu'il
existe aujourd'hui est artificielle ça
veut pas dire que je suis contre les
honneurs c'est à dire que je suis contre
l'idée qu' on est dans un modèle qui
soit aujourd'hui vertueux les et les
nerfs me semble-t-il fonctionne à partir
du moment où vous venez d'un scénario
très carbonées et là vous pouvez
potentiellement mettre des nerfs mais
encore une fois il faut bien comprendre
que vous êtes dans une logique de prix
qui est sponsorisé est ce que vous
pouvez vous nous dire quelques mots sur
astrid ou superphénix
catastrophe voilà c'est pour moi c'est
des catastrophes parce que ce sont des
exemplaires uniques de recherche et pour
des raisons idéologiques et pour avoir
l'assurance qu'on allait détruire cette
filière les ministres principalement
écologistes anti nucléaires ont réussi à
emporter ou des d'ailleurs des alliances
entre l'écologiste et différents types
de gouvernement ont aussi emporté ses
décisions c'est juste irresponsable
superphénix était un échec dès le début
il ya eu des déboires des surcoûts
l'immense cu énormément je crois du
facteur moyen sur l'ensemble de sa durée
de vie c'est quelques % à 15 % peut-être
une grand maximum je crois que j'irai
moi-même et au mieux il a fonctionné une
année à 30% de facteurs de charge de
retourner on est plutôt sur des niveaux
vraiment dérisoire il ya aucune chance
enfin n'y a aucune certitude en tout cas
que que ces réacteurs de 4ème génération
utt compétitifs s'ils avaient été vus le
jour et pour astrid alors c'est en
partie une décision politique c'est
aussi une décision du ca face à au fait
que aussi politiquement on a fait le
choix de se tourner vers le p r et que
en gros pour les 20 prochaines années le
mot d'ordre c'était on va faire des
repères on va rien faire d'autre et ça
aussi décourager le ceva qui a d'abord
revu à la baisse le projet d'astrid en
termes de puissance
on est passé de ces chiffres mais de
quelques centaines de mégawatts à
seulement une centaine
et du coup ça a fini par l'abandon mais
c'est pas uniquement due à des choix
politiques de ministre c'est aussi dû à
des choix industriels de se focaliser et
de s'obstiner sur le p r avec les
conséquences qu'on connaît et le fiasco
qui a eu lieu donc c'est un peu plus
compliqué que ça
non je suis pas d'accord mais si t'es
pas d'accord vous expliquer non mais je
pense que sur astrid effectivement il ya
eu un choix ou on sait il ya eu un
moment on s'est dit on peut pas s'offrir
d'avoir deux filières dans le contexte
actuel un contiennent un contexte qui
était en dessous nucléaire pour faire ce
genre de choses et
donc on a décidé d'arrêter ça mais
astrid était quelque chose d extrêmement
prometteur et qui aurait dû et les deux
outils étaient les outils
essentiellement de recherche et donc je
trouve que quoi qu'on pense de ces
systèmes pour la recherche si on aurait
dû les conserver et superphénix et 100%
une décision politique c'était même un
deal me semble-t-il d'une alliance entre
les verts et le gouvernement jospin il
me semble lorsqu'ils sont arrivés au
pouvoir comme lui
on arrive bientôt à la fin de notre
émission est ce que vous voulez parler
d'un coup qu'on n'a pas abordé alors
chacun le droit un point
non je pense qu'il ya un point qui est
intéressant et qui était un peu
périphériques à tout ça c'est les
scénarios de décroissance énergétique
est-ce qu'ils sont crédibles ou pas
de stabilité sociale
oui sans doute c'est
bon personnellement je pense que
l'énergie est très mal utilisé
on a vu l'exemple des véhicules qui sont
utilisés par 1,1 une personne
etc du capital qui est immobilisé qui
sert à rien on a la même chose dans les
immeubles de rapport sert les immeubles
de bureaux comme ici et le taux des
usages c'est 24% c'est tout à fait
aberrant et donc je
je trouve que c'est un sujet qui mérite
d'être abordée parce que finalement
effectivement on est pour on est contre
le nucléaire on est pour ou contre les
1er mai ce sujet et dominant en fait
dire qu'on doit réussir à faire en sorte
que avec le moins de frottements
possible on est une efficacité de
l'usagé énergétique plus important hélas
a rejoint quand même un peu mon domaine
qui est celui de l'utilisation de la
technologie numérique pour augmenter sa
on a parlé un peu mais je pense que
c'est vraiment important d'insister là
dessus en fait on est dans une situation
catastrophique pour les deux prochains
hivers en termes de risque de black out
mais aussi en termes de risque social
parce qu'on va avoir des prix d'énergie
qui vont vraiment explosé on va voir un
prix l'électricité qui probablement cet
hiver pendant un certain moment va être
ou des fous d après vous la réquisition
de groupes électrogènes du datacenter ou
disent ils savent où ça c'est pour
éviter un black out mais c'est déjà ce
que ce sera suffisant et puis ça va pas
empêcher les prix d'être vraiment
faramineux pour l'heure pas forcément
directement pour les particuliers parce
qu'il ya un certain nombre de mécanismes
pour empêcher des prix enfin une
dépendance directe au marché par contre
quid du temps pour les industriels et
pour les entreprises c'est une vraie
question on est au bord d'une crise
sociale
majeure en fait il serait vraiment temps
de prendre des mesures d'urgence pour
anticiper ces deux hivers des mesures de
sobriété de couper tous les écrans
numériques publicitaires qu'on voit
fleurir un peu partout au moins pendant
les périodes difficiles moi je pense
qu'il faudrait carrément les enlever à
long terme parce que c'est vraiment de
l'ébriété est dure et personne n'en veut
à part aller publicitaire de même si
c'est un peu juste pour cet hiver mais
pour l'hiver prochain de vraiment lancer
un plan de rénovation performant des
passoires thermiques faut savoir qu'il
ya 5 à 8 millions de logements passoires
ses 12 millions de personnes qui ont
froid ou qui ont du mal à chauffer
chaque chaque hiver
de développer aussi enfin de lancer les
projets qui sont bloqués de cergy
renouvelables qui sont en attente parce
que il ya des dossiers qui sont blessés
en préfecture parce qu'il n'ya pas assez
de moyens humains qui sont mis dans les
dents les dans la justice pour pour
traiter les recours qui sont normaux et
qu'il faut continuer à voir mais qu'il
faut traiter plus rapidement que c'est
fait aujourd'hui typiquement il ya
plusieurs gigawatts et voire même
jusqu'à une dizaine de gigawatts
d'éolien et une dizaine de gigawatts de
photovoltaïque qui pourrait être sortie
d'ici un an et demi si on accélère et
tout ça en fait c'est des mesures qui
sont vraiment essentiel si on veut
limiter un petit peu la catastrophe qui
nous attend pour les deux prochains
hivers une question qui n'a rien à voir
denis à votre voisin de droite ou de
gauche ce que vous avez apprécié est ce
que vous n'avez pas apprécié est ce que
vous voudriez pour le prochain débat
pour améliorer le débat
je peux peut-être commencé moi j'ai
plutôt risation de gilles
j'ai beaucoup apprécié ce débat qui
globalement est resté assez apposé
apaisé on sait pas couper la parole ou
ouais c'est peu et on a pu vraiment
prendre le temps de deux d'exposer nos
positionnements qui sont effectivement
divergent sur beaucoup d'aspects mais
qui se rejoignent aussi sur certains vie
et de consommation et de l'urgence
après il ya eu quelques petits moments
où il ya eu
un peu frites et met gentiment
ce sérieuse et oui c'est aussi voilà
mais sinon qu'est ce qui a amélioré
qu'est ce qu'il faudrait faire
une question
d'être un fact checking plus rapide ou
mais cécile affaire
c'est extrêmement difficile c'est déjà
sur le bon chemin gilles qu'est ce que
tu as aimé que ses tapas et mais qu'est
ce qu'il faut améliorer parce que j'ai
pas aimé à sept îles et anti-nucléaires
les mêmes moments ici non je trouve très
sympathique ce débat et je je je suis
enfin je trouve qu'on devrait plus avoir
de débat comme ça c'est à dire des
débats on a le temps donc ça ça n'existe
pas moi je me retrouve tout le temps
d'un des trucs tu as vingt minutes et tu
dois développer un truc complexe donc ça
merci à vous je pense que c'est vraiment
super et puis je trouve que voilà il est
courtois et c'est très agréable
c'est pas je me dis pas toujours cette
ce type de qualité de contradicteur me
faut trois livres comme conseil à lire
pour notre communiqué communauté chacun
et un conseil pour les jeunes
générations nicolas trois livres un
conseil pour les jeunes générations
qui connaissent alors celui qui commence
n'aura pas le mot de la fin
ok alors gilles tu commence comme ça
lance xavier
[Musique]
dans les livres classiques moi il ya un
livre que je trouve incroyable dans le
temps mais quand même je ne peux pas ne
pas leur corps n'est pas ce que j'ai
déjà offert au moins une quinzaine de
fois c'est le monde hier de stefan zweig
je trouve c'est vraiment pour comprendre
l'europe c'est extraordinaire
comme comme livre
qu'est ce que je lis en ce moment est
prêt même si je me souviens pas des
titres des livres que je dis donc ça
aide pas beaucoup
attendent quoi
c'est un livre sur le désastre de la
génération des boomers des
commandes passées à son fils prendre
nucléaire que c'est ça ça doit être cela
aussi en gros les soirs les comme on
appelle ça les ceux qui sont nés pour
mai 68 la les
victimes
générations
tous ceux qui sont nés en 45 voilà donc
c'est et qui montrent que ces gens là
sont ils ont été tout à fait
irresponsable sur le plan économique sur
le plan environnemental sur le plan
social et j'ai trouvé ce livre à la fois
très très dur maintenant très juste mais
je n'ai plus le titre de ce livre
troisième livre qu'est ce que je
pourrais dire
alors je veux pas leur commander mais
j'ai lu un truc très ancien qui est la
révolte qui vient du comité invisible ça
m'a très anciens grâce à une bonne
douzaine d'années je pense à ça m'a
profondément agacé mais j'ai les vues de
bout en bout je définis il ya quelques
quelques semaines
voilà comme ça je pourrais dire que je
les lui
il s'était bien mais je trouve que
d'abord le ton est extrêmement
prétentieux ça mérite d'être dit quand
même je trouve que c'est un espèce de
melon qui sort de sa qui met dans sa
logique dans la logique de ce comité son
mode par exemple d'agression des
des systèmes de pouvoir qui sont les
nôtres d'interconnexion laineux
d'énergie les noeuds de
les systèmes d'interconnexion c'est
assez intéressant ça permet d' je me
demandais si d'ailleurs les pires
opposante séjour lasserre les forces de
police l'avait jamais lu en tout cas ils
devraient le dire parce qu'ils
comprendraient de produc
nicolas tran livre ouais alors le
premier en lien avec la thématique petit
traité de sobriété énergétique de
barbara nicoloso qui justement développe
un peu ce qu est la sobriété et qu'est
ce que pourrait être une société
construite autour de la sobriété
énergétique mais aussi aux matériaux etc
donc c'est assez intéressant pour
s'ouvrir là dessus en deuxième livre je
dirais le livre et si
qu'on a écrit avec alternatiba et
pendant le confinement et qui emploie le
terme au tibet c'est une association du
mouvement climat qui en gros mythe
milite pour changer le système et non le
climat et qui organise notamment est une
des grosse organisation qui organise les
grandes marches climat qui peut y avoir
en france et c'est un livre en fête où
il ya une trentaine d'intellectuels dont
un bon nombre sont passés par chez toi
donc alain damasio corinne morel darleux
cédric héroux
dominique méda bon bref je préfère tout
de la liste mais il a plein aussi
illustré qui essayent d'imaginer qu'est
ce que pourrait être le monde d'après
sur tout un tas de thématiques sur le
déplacement sur le travail sur loisirs
etc donc c'est assez intéressant pour
s'ouvrir à un nouveau récit est le
dernier livre un peu plus personnel je
dirais la fabrique du monstre de
philippe poujol qui en gros une enquête
dans les quartiers nord de marseille est
aussi sur le système gaudin donc de jean
claude gaudin le maire pendant plusieurs
décennies de marseille pour en fait
expliqué comment un système mafieux a
créé vraiment
une certaine certaines zones en
déshérence total et en extrême pauvreté
et qui moi aussi me questionne sur
20 sur à quel point nos régimes
politiques peuvent être
intrigué mais pourri par par un certain
nombre d'acteurs alors c'était
clairement le cas à marseille quand on
voit ce qui s'est passé à gaudin est ce
que c'est le cas aussi au niveau
national peut être pas telle ampleur
mais ça ça mérite au moins deux
questionnaires gilles un conseil pour
les jeunes générations
moi je pense que
[Musique]
les jeunes générations doivent
prendre le pouvoir
et à comment par la force
c'est peut-être le moyen le moins
efficace en fait alors il faut déserté
non je par tous les moyens mais en tout
cas je suis convaincue qu' il ya une
forme de faillite morale des générations
qui ont précédé et que
voilà et d'ailleurs c'est ce qu'elles
disent moi quand je parle avec mes
neveux
avec des gens qui ont entre 12 et 20 ans
aujourd'hui
ils sont pas du tout si désengager qu'on
le dit ils sont même je trouve très
engagé mais sait même pas qui nous juge
c'est qu'ils négligent mère qui
considère que notamment sur les enjeux
écologiques
c'est même pas un débat ils veulent pas
discuter avec nous quand c'est très et
je sais c'est pas quelque chose que je
firme au travers d'une ou deux
conversations c'est quelque chose que
j'observe de façon assez systémique
donc prendre le pouvoir
nicolas assez proche peut-être engager
vous tout simplement ben c'est simple
engagez vous pour vos convictions pour
ce que vous voulez défendre il ya un
monde qui a au moins 1 re phase au néant
grande fierté peut-être même à refonder
en grande partie et c'est pas vous que
ça va passer donc engager vous en
politique engagez-vous dans des ong
engagez-vous dans des syndicats etc il
ya dix mille formes
façon de s'engager à plein-temps
professionnellement bénévolement et
s'est donc fait le pour vos convictions
si vous en avez les moyens évidemment ce
que ce n'est pas le cas de tout le monde
mais c'est vraiment important parce que
malheureusement les générations plus
anciennes ne le ferons pas
nicolas gill merci
[Musique]
non